Yeah, he's the Groot, right?
Yeah, Bogred messaged me last night.
He's like, I'm gonna ban Groot first thing.
And I was like, oh, okay.
We could just ban the Strange.
I just got the Celestial.
I didn't play Rank, like, for two weeks.
And then yesterday, I just grinded from Celestial 3 to 1, so...
I was like, I literally got back from Japan.
At like 5, and I was like, oh, fuck, okay.
I need to play.
Let's go.
Wait, I was bragging about being Plat 1.
You're Celestial?
What the fuck?
That's not even high.
It's not even Eternity.
Wait, am I the most assed one then?
Cause...
No, isn't it?
Yeah, see?
This team is actually kind of high rated.
I think we can extend a massive chance here.
I think we could just ban... If we ban Bogr's Strange, then, like, both our tank players aren't playing their mains.
So, like...
Cause I know Bogr's banning Groot.
He literally just...
He, like, the first thing he messaged me was just, I'm banning Groot for your team.
I was like, okay.
Yeah, but I can play all the tanks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we just play it then, like...
I mostly play Strategist.
But I can play, like, Punisher or Hella for DPS.
Mmm...
Both are good.
I think if we play Raccoon, then they play Punisher.
I think we just hold that thing on their shield.
Yeah, I can play a Raccoon for a Punisher.
No, I'm not gonna lie.
Listen, listen.
I'm like a... I can make strats for us, whatever, on the fly.
Like, we could beat better teams, right?
We're just, like, better strats.
Like, if they're playing, like, tanks or whatever, and their best are on tank, and we're having a hard time...
We don't even play Raccoon.
We don't even play Squirrel Girl.
Maybe I'll have you on Punisher, and you just left-click the shields and the walls, and then they can't do anything.
Okay.
Yeah, they're not used to playing against Squirrel Girl, so it's, like, a huge surprise, too.
They're like, what the fuck do we do?
Wait, does nobody really play her?
She's so fun to play.
I avoid every Squirrel player I see.
Some players, some players.
If any of you are really good at DPS, the other healer I've played is Rocket.
So I can do Rocket if I need to.
I mean, we could run triple support if we're desperate.
Okay.
That's, like, the desperate strat.
Yeah, we do.
Does anyone have xQc on their friends list?
I'm in the lobby right now.
My name is pvc in the game.
Just add pvc.
Huh?
Add pvc, please.
I'm not gonna lie, man, you're gonna have to type that.
You're gonna have to type it.
pvc, pvc.
Fell off?
Is that your group?
Yes, yes, fell off.
Invite, please.
I added and invited.
Yeah, thank you.
And invite, I don't see it yet.
Oh, can I get an invite?
Are you saying pvc or bbc?
pvc.
Yeah, I got it.
Who asked for an invite?
Okay.
Wait, do I see...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, their team is straight bonkers.
Huge balls, come on in.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, okay, by the way, guys, I play a lot of Penny.
I can sort of play Magneto.
I can also support for us.
So I'm very like tank, support, fill.
I feel like actually this works out so well because I think we have the exact amount of players for each role, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Does anyone know what the first map is or is it like randomized?
I have no idea how, I think it'll be a random map.
I thought we could choose our map.
I think each team gets to pick one.
Yeah.
All right.
So we're doing like, oh, so who's picking first then?
I have no clue.
Oh, it's not random?
Oh, no, I didn't read the rules.
Toast was like, you want to join?
I was like, yeah.
That's really it.
Do we know who we want to reserve?
I think Scroll Girl.
Oh, that's a good idea.
Maybe.
Unless they didn't research, if they didn't, I don't, it's a forefront term.
There's no way they researched.
They probably have like a Marvel Rivals like tracker website pulled up right now.
Yeah, they're just like, what's the scene at play with the Scroll Girl icon?
That's why I have a Black Panther icon on, so people don't know.
It's a suit.
Throw them off.
If they don't ban Groot, do we want to save that?
No, not really.
I can play the other ones.
They're just as good.
Okay.
Is it Discord overlay down or is it just me?
No, it's working.
Oh, that's weird.
It's not working for me.
The ones that they have that they always give us are pretty bad.
I like the one that doesn't have, I think, above it and only ticks whenever you're talking.
I'll make my own, I think.
Do you have a Discord admin?
I do.
I don't, actually.
I do, but for some reason, it's not working for me, which is weird.
No, Discord just had their big update today.
Yeah.
Yeah, it says the resource is being rate limited.
I was like, what the fuck does that mean?
Yeah, I don't know.
Tech doesn't know me.
Yeah, they tweaked their layout a little bit.
Oh, I didn't even notice.
I don't think mine is updated yet.
Is it bad?
Because then I'll try to stop it.
I don't know.
Like, I saw someone tweet like a side-by-side comparison and the differences was like very minimum.
So...
Okay.
Dude, I'm not gonna lie.
I thought that, like, you guys were around my ranking and I wasn't gonna be the noob on the team.
And I didn't know that all of you guys were like...
No, it's like each row is its own tier.
Yeah, you guys are crazy.
But you're not gold.
Okay, like some people on the other team.
Oh, hey, but Shoto is...
Wasn't Shoto in Vacation too?
I was gonna say, I assumed...
I think I've played with Shoto before.
Wasn't he like Grandmaster?
No, he peaked Diamond.
He peaked Diamond.
Yeah, but they moved him down.
For...
Another player.
I'm hearing some rumors right now.
Oh, what's the rumor?
What rumors?
Somebody said it.
Senna is black, but she's actually silver in disguise.
We're ready, right?
That's so bad.
I mean, I bet that guy is bad.
Tell me that wasn't one of your mods, because I know it wasn't.
I'm not fucking silver, man.
Tell me you can't get the Platinum 1 with only Squirrel Girl.
Who can do that?
I've seen Squirrel Girls in one of them all.
I've been bragging about Plat 1 this whole time.
Is that not even good?
No, honestly, I think...
I think Plat 1 is pretty good.
Yeah, Plat 1 is really good.
I think Plat C...
Is that one tier away from Diamond, or...?
Yeah, that's one tier away from Diamond, yeah.
Yeah.
There are some people that will never get out of Bronze.
Ever.
In their life.
Okay.
Be proud.
Yeah.
Yeah, and you got out of there with Squirrel Girl.
Maybe Wolverine?
Does that...
I think...
Does any of them play Wolverine?
Yeah, we should ban Wolverine for sure.
Yeah.
It counters almost all of our characters.
I banned it.
Nice.
And then maybe...
I don't know.
I know Booger plays Bruce.
If he can't play Strange.
So...
Oh, there he goes.
Yeah, but they saved now.
He's gonna save Strange.
Who do we wanna save?
I feel like we don't really need to save anybody in general.
Yeah, I don't think we're gonna ban anybody we play.
No, now we have to ban Strange because they're gonna run Gamma.
We could...
We have to save someone.
Yeah.
Save Strange.
Oh, I saved Strange.
Yeah, because...
Yeah, no, no.
And then I ban Bruce.
Wait, why?
Because I have to play Strange with Penny.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, is it the only thing you can play?
No, no, it works with Penny the best.
Oh!
Yeah.
We need a shield.
We could just ban another support so they can't run Trip Support.
We ban Hela?
Sure, we ban Hela, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, it's so over.
No, it's not.
Wait, why?
Why?
Guys, I've never even seen the ban screen before.
I knew it!
Oh, wow.
They really want those skins.
But I didn't want to be that guy.
Are we running Trip Support, everyone?
Yeah, we can run this for Trip Support.
Who could it be?
So, four supports, maybe?
Maybe just play Poki.
I'll switch to Rocket, I'll switch to Rocket.
If you're going Punisher, Lulu.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Triple Sup Rocket, Punisher is actually better.
Poki, do you want to play...
I can play any...
I can play any support.
We shouldn't run Rocket as a duo support.
It doesn't work that way.
Okay.
I can play Cloak as well.
Yeah, can we just go Trip Support?
Yeah.
Yeah, Trip Support actually kind of collapses.
It's meta, it's meta.
Yeah, Trip Support is good.
It's good, but we can't have Rocket as a duo support.
Yeah, this is good.
This comp actually works.
I'll just put... I'll put it on...
The Snowflake on the next QC.
So you will never die.
The most annoying character lineup ever.
I love it.
This is an interesting lineup.
I'm careful on the ult.
I'll try to freeze.
I'll try to freeze the ult.
Oh, Iron Man up top.
Can you get me an Infinite around this corner?
Yeah.
I'm walking up.
Yeah, I'm pushing up, pushing up.
It's kind of hard for me to hit Iron Man's FYI, so...
I'll try, but...
I'll try to shoot him too.
There's a Hulk behind us, Hulk behind.
Yeah, he's destroying the respawn.
He's low, he's half.
He's gonna die.
Have him out of the...
He's literally one shot, but...
He's healed, he's healed, he's healed.
I'm in the back.
Okay.
Um, what do you have now?
I'm getting one.
Got him.
Nice.
Tracer's low.
Iron Man dead.
I have, uh...
the...
Relay and one.
Push up with XTC.
Oh, Tracer's half, Tracer's half, Tracer's half.
Tracer's low, Tracer's low.
Tracer's one, Tracer's one.
Still one, still one.
You push it, you push it.
Nice.
Oh.
Ooh.
Sorry.
I can't see XTC.
Use ult if you have to, use ult if you have to.
I don't have ult, I don't have support ult yet.
No, no, no.
Oh, I didn't need to ult.
I... I have a 75.
I got it, I got it.
I got mine, I got mine.
Nice.
Just push up with him.
Push up, push up, push up.
If you guys want me to.
Okay, I'll ult after.
I'm coming back with Punisher ult.
They have Hulk ult.
I'm damage boosting.
Yup, yup, yup, yup.
Three, two, one.
I got the Lucio.
Both Lucio dead, both Lucio dead.
Still have it, still have it, still have it.
It's in the boost, it's in the boost.
We're even, we're even, we're even, we're even.
We're up one, we're up one.
Can you guys push up, can you guys push up?
You can kill the Mantis, she only has one personal.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I'll bubble here, I'll bubble here.
I got your ult.
And I don't got you.
Hey, sub, did they Hulk ult that?
Uh, no.
Please don't have it.
Oh my god, I didn't even...
Oh, strange was half.
They only used one support ult for that fight.
Keep doing what you're doing now.
Just pressure tanks, pressure ground, then we're chilling.
We're doing really good.
We still have one more support ult.
I'm almost right here.
I could die.
Strange is... oh, he's too weak.
Hulk has.
I'm going around to try to get their healers here.
Yep.
I'm gonna follow you.
Oh, no.
You guys are kind of split on the left side.
You guys, you guys, we're winning, we're winning, we're winning.
Am I getting ult?
There you go.
Oh my god.
I'm coming back with a Punisher ult again.
Oh, I couldn't get it off.
He interrupted.
No.
I got Agamotto'd.
Yeah.
Reset, reset.
Reset it, reset it, reset it, reset it.
We'll have to ult the last point.
One last fight.
What support ults do they have?
Uh...
They don't have Invis.
They should have Cloak.
They just used Invis.
Just assume support ults.
I'll have Cloak ult in 20%.
They have Mantis Cloak.
They used Train.
They should have Hulk ult.
Just focus Train.
Focus Train, focus Train.
Kill him, kill him.
I'm blocking him, I'm blocking him.
He's half.
Just go into him, go into him, go into him really hard.
I froze him, I froze him.
I got killed by my ult.
I got killed by everything.
They used Cloak as well.
This is good.
Make sure you use Luna, Luna.
I'm waiting.
Do we have Luna ult?
Luna ult?
Yeah, we need it, we need it.
Okay, I used mine.
Nice.
Last fight, last fight.
Use everything you have.
Stay on my ult.
Stay on my ult if you can.
Nice.
I'm damage boosting this.
I'm damage boosting.
Train, Train, Train.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got you, I got you.
YOLO dude, YOLO dude, YOLO dude.
Nice, nice.
Someone's up top.
Someone's up here.
This Hulker is kind of low.
I don't think we can let him out.
Nice.
Okay.
He's coming back in, he's coming back in, he's coming back in.
I couldn't freeze him in time.
They're going to TP, they're going to TP.
Focus Hulk, focus Hulk.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
Focus him, focus him, focus him.
Strange Hab, Strange Hab.
Strange one, strange one.
Nice, nice.
Cloak, Cloak, focus Cloak.
I froze her, I froze her.
Nice.
Good job guys.
Good freeze.
Yo, keep doing that.
Like, we need to just pressure the tanks really hard.
See, like, their Hulk is not diving.
We need to just keep doing that.
Otherwise he dives and we get cucked.
Someone's going to play up with you.
Nice guys, good job.
We're in this, let's go.
This is really good.
Pushing first is really, really hard here.
Wait guys, can we triple push the payload?
I'm using any of my support ult.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Yeah, they're going to ult Cloak anyway.
Yeah, let's get out of this Cloak.
I hate this Cloak.
Hulk, Hulk coming up.
Hulk is down, Hulk down.
I'm stunned here.
I'm on Tracer.
Yeah, for the tanks, for the tanks.
Change ult, change ult.
Tracer's solo.
Change one.
Tracer's solo here.
I froze ult, I froze ult.
I'm back gap, I'm back gap.
I can't be in the ult.
Back gap, back gap, back gap.
Don't use ult, don't use ult.
We're one down one right now.
I'm trying to freeze them.
Oh no.
This is good, this is good, this is good.
Yeah, just don't use anything.
They used Hulk ult and invisible woman for this.
I have ult.
I have ult in 10.
I think I can, I can...
I can ult for our Punisher and then you can just walk forward with it.
I don't see Hulk.
Yeah, I think they're just playing main.
Yeah, Hulk is over here.
I'm just pushing tanks, pushing tanks here.
I'm down for that.
Yeah, just ult when they have ult.
If you ult, I'll ult.
He's solo, he's solo.
Got you, I got you.
Oh good.
I'm damage boosting, I'm damage boosting it.
He'll do it, he'll do it.
Damage boost, push forward, push forward, damage boost.
Just keep pushing forward.
We have cold ult.
Nice.
Push up, let's go.
We have no defensive ult so we have to be aggressive here.
Oh, I can TP them.
Nah, they're gonna TP themselves.
They have, they have Bucky ult here.
Okay, we have Raccoon ult early.
We need the Raccoon ult early to pressure up.
Yeah, you should call for it.
Yeah, no, whatever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Infinite, infinite, infinite.
Hulk's frozen.
Hulk low, Hulk low.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Stranger's so weak.
Bucky's low.
Nevermind, he's got heal.
Oh, you're in a room, you're in a room.
Hang on, I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
This is the last fight, last fight.
Use everything you have.
Lose everything.
This is the last fight.
Bucky low, Bucky low.
I'll have ult soon if we can stay, if we can stay.
Okay, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Yeah, just ult, just ult.
Use everything.
Last fight.
They're backline, they're backline, they're backline.
Oh no.
Are we on it?
We're on it, we're on it.
We're safe, we're safe, we're safe.
I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
Hulk low, Hulk, Hulk is low.
Strange ult, strange, strange, strange, strange.
I have ult here, I have ult here.
I'm using it.
I'm damage boosting it.
Back to support, heal.
Damage boosting again.
Oh no.
Winnable still.
Yeah, we're even, we're even.
Oh, we see nice.
Oh my god.
I'm not gonna lie, I was about to hit the absolute most obese ult of all time.
Like, they were all lined up and I had full juice.
That's what I did.
15.
Yeah, it's just like the...
Like the support ult in tandem, like charade back to back to back.
It's just kind of crazy.
It's a good push though.
Yeah.
I'll ult for a strange ult for us.
So like, if the strange comes in, you don't have to worry about it.
Guys, I don't know what to do.
Like, right now we should not be scared with the way we pushed and our results.
Like, this is actually good.
Let's not change anything.
Keep the formula.
And we just pressure tanks really hard.
See their tanks?
They're kind of doing like almost nothing.
Like, they're having a hard time.
We keep doing that.
Their Red Spurs are on tank.
Just bust the shields.
Make them like lose confidence.
You win this.
See, like I'm telling you, when you're breaking shield, like their strange, like he's doing nothing.
Like, he's out of tools, you know?
So, you know, maybe you feel useless.
You're not useless.
Breaking shield.
Mhm.
Real.
I'm telling you.
So real.
The guy was always hiding and then going to the corners because he can't stay main.
You're breaking shield.
Oh, alright.
Also, the Ironman Hulk team is not a strong team.
You don't have to be afraid.
Oh, I'm reloading.
I hear someone behind me.
Is that a Psylocke?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But she's back on main.
She's back on main.
Just let me know when you turn.
Nice, nice.
We're up one.
So don't be afraid.
Behind the...
On the right, on the right.
Break that shit.
Break it, break it.
Thanks.
Infinite whenever you have it on this corner.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's in.
I'm reloading.
I can't see you all.
I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
I placed it.
No!
It's fine, you're fine.
You're safe, you're safe, you're safe.
Hulk on the right, Hulk on the right.
Behind.
On the cart, on the cart.
He's so weak.
I have ult.
Okay, back up a little bit.
I'm not fully defensible.
Okay, stay alive, stay alive, stay alive.
Don't panic, don't panic.
Stay together.
Back up a little to the right, to the right.
Okay, we need to retake, we need to retake.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have to die here.
I can't live.
I tried to back away from that, I couldn't.
Hulk's pushed up.
I feel like we're winning this somehow.
When they push out, I can use ult right now on this Hulk.
Hulk's all the way in our backline.
We should push early.
They have...
They have a lot of distance here.
Yeah, yeah.
I need heals.
Where do you want me to place it?
Like up here?
I froze him, I froze him, I froze him.
He has ult though.
Stranger's leash.
I'm saving my ult for a stranger ult, so Poki can ult whenever.
Hulk is literally one shot.
Hulk is one, Hulk is one.
Okay, I'm gonna come back with my ult.
That's fine, that's fine.
When she's done, I can use my ult.
We need to go back a little bit, we need to go back a little bit.
Yep.
Yeah, we need it like sooner.
I froze Hulk.
I'm gonna wait for her thing to go away.
I need it, I need it, I need it.
If you can keep me up, then...
Yeah, we need it, we need it, we need it, we need it now.
Like now, now, now, now, now.
I need heals, I need heals, I need heals.
I can't see you, I...
Yeah, I don't see you, I can't see you.
We see you now, we see you.
Strange one, strange one, strange half.
Nice, nice, nice.
Hulk's in that hallway.
We can get him, get him.
I froze him.
Oh, nice.
Stagger, stagger.
Don't kill him, don't kill him, don't kill him.
Stagger him, stagger him.
Just leave him, leave him.
Oh my god, he was literally the one.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
There's kills if you have...
Yeah, push up more, push up more.
Get out, get out.
Back up a bit.
We need to back up a bit.
Good job, guys.
Portal, portal, portal, portal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, down the corner, corner, here, right here.
Right here, right here.
Together, together.
Uh, I don't have relay yet.
I got it.
Don't worry.
Nice, nice, nice.
Good ult.
I'm damage boosting.
Should I ult?
There's Psylocke on the backline.
On the cart.
Stay healthy.
Come back a bit.
Punisher, yep.
Ult here, ult here, ult here.
I'm ulting.
I'm on Hulk.
Hulk die, Hulk die.
No!
And he reloaded.
There's a Hulk in our backlines.
Oh my god, Hulk is literally one in the back.
I can't do anything.
It's just you and I.
Oh, I'm running back.
Dang it.
We still have one more map here.
It's best of three.
Oh my god.
I think it's just two games, no?
Yeah, it's two games.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
At the end of the day, this game is a lot closer than it looks.
It's not...
Like, we're doing really good.
I do think the combination...
The Gamma, Gamma's ruling us.
I'm not kidding.
Just the fact that they have Hulk is...
Like, it's not that the Hulk is killing us.
It's that they have Hulk.
Does that make sense?
Because Gamma is very strong.
Yeah.
Did he play Strange?
And Hulk?
Yeah, because SageM's a Strange player.
The MvC4, he's a Strange player.
Or Strange main.
Oh, they have...
So we could ban Strange.
I would like to ban Strange.
And then they'll both be Strange players, technically.
Yeah.
But they're just gonna protect Hulk for Bulger.
Because he plays Hulk for his team, too.
See, we have a lot of damage.
Like, we're not doing bad.
It's just...
Oh.
I said that in team chat.
Someone will tell him.
Word will get back around.
Guys, I will perform better, okay?
No, you did great!
We're going to dress the elephant in the room, okay?
No, I don't...
I don't even think it was your fault.
I think it was...
I don't think I was very...
Listen, I'm not kidding.
You had pretty good damage.
That's really, really good, yeah.
It's just about, like...
In the end, they're gonna have to support ults.
Because they have three support ults.
And we have two.
Because Raccoon's ult is then, like, a real ult, right?
Right, right.
That's great.
I can play Mantis.
Yeah, Mantis works.
If we do triple support, Mantis is, like, one of the best for trip support.
Just because, like, of the speed boost.
Yeah.
It really is, like, whatever you're comfortable.
I can play any other support.
So, I can flex anything you guys are comfortable with.
I think they're doing good right now.
That we're not doing is that...
They're, like, backing and stabilizing.
When they're, like, down by one.
Or, like...
We use a certain ult.
We need to be able to do something.
Like, whenever they use a support ult like that...
We have to, like, back out of it.
And everybody gets out.
So, now we're in a bit of a de-sync.
Like, we have, like, two groups right now.
We need to be one group.
We need to get out of their ult.
And just keep going backwards.
And just stabilize our HP.
Yeah.
Sounds good.
We can stabilize more frequently.
Not me, personally.
I think that was a fluke.
It doesn't fucking matter what we do.
It'll be fine.
We win this.
No, if that was caught, like, uh...
Domination, we win this, by the way.
Listen, there's little things.
Sure.
But, really, it's because they had Strange and Bruce...
...at the same fucking time.
That's the only reason.
They have two tank players.
How could this be?
And they got both of the most fucking annoying tanks.
And they ban me?
Little ol' me on little ol' Penny?
Yeah, like, do they really need more?
How could you nerf us more?
You're on Penny!
I can't believe...
They're just afraid of your Penny, Poki.
They're so afraid.
What?
They were like, her Penny is the game changer.
Like, it would've been, like, an easy 1-0.
I just can't believe them.
Yeah, this time, I think we...
I thought we were friends.
We ban Strange, save Penny, and our win rate goes up, like, 90%.
Yeah, exactly.
We gotta do that.
And then they ban Penny first.
If they ban Penny first, they're that afraid of you.
That should be an honor.
I agree.
You got one above all player to ban Penny.
Then we get Groot, so it's okay.
Yeah.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
This...
By the way, Challa is really good for Penny, so...
Girl, I know.
Let's get it!
You're like, this ain't my first video.
I hope I get it.
Is the whole tournament, is it all Convoy?
No, you get to pick them out.
Yeah, yeah, I pick Challa.
I pick Challa for us.
Convoy is, like, the best.
It's so fun.
I love it.
Yeah, I'm looking for fun right now.
I'm trying to win the game.
Those 47 skins are so... guys, guys.
Those add up, guys.
I'm not gonna lie, I do really want that.
I do, I do.
You see the wonder of life.
Wait, they didn't ban anybody.
Oh, gosh.
They messed up the ban.
Oh my gosh!
Good for us.
We getting strange out of here.
I think we ban Strange.
Yeah, we ban Strange.
That's super one special right there.
No.
Exactly.
Me.
Very saving.
Will decide.
Can I save Penny?
Yeah, save Penny.
Dang.
Yay!
Let's have a good time.
Okay, so I guess we're gonna run double support then.
And we're gonna... if Hoagie's gonna be on Penny.
I don't even know why they're saving Hoagie.
Cringe.
It doesn't even make any sense yet.
I don't know.
Cringe.
I guess...
Then I think I'm just gonna ban Mag then.
Yeah, just ban Mag.
Let them not run normal comp.
Yeah, they have no tank.
They have no tank to play now.
I don't know who they'll play with.
This is fine.
I'm okay with this.
Wait, do you play Cloak and Dagger or Luna?
I can play Luna.
Yeah, okay.
I'll play... you can play Irelia, whichever is your best.
Because Mantis is not as great for duo support anymore.
I can play Cloak.
Okay.
Do you want me... I can do Moon Knight or Punisher or Namor.
Maybe Moon Knight on this one?
Are we defense?
Oh, okay, it's Coff.
Yeah, right.
Oh, no.
This is like the most off meta stuff I've ever played, so I don't know what goes well.
What am I doing?
I'm just like, I'm looking at my T as like...
I don't know what goes well with this team.
Feel free to suggest whatever you'd like.
Do you guys want to go straight side or do you want to fight up top?
I think we...
Also, Dokkae next, you guys should definitely like over communicate.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't ever shut up.
Go right, yeah, go right, like under, under and then we meet them like an L shape.
I don't want to go in, I don't want to go in.
Just go here.
I'm right behind you guys.
Just follow, just follow XTC.
I'm up.
I'm psyched.
Jesus Christ, you take so much damage.
That's fine.
Nice.
I froze him, I froze him, I froze him.
Reloading.
Got you.
Okay.
Oh, nice!
Okay, Senna!
Oh, thanks guys, A team.
Guys, I feel like...
I can't see, I can't see, I can't see, I can't see.
...or something.
It's okay, it's okay, back up, back up.
You guys are okay numbers though.
I froze him, I froze him.
Just kill him.
Senna's one.
Five, five, five.
Massive.
They only have rocket, they only have rocket, they only have rocket.
Nice.
Senna's low.
He's hard.
I need it.
I need a heal.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Good job, guys.
There are only a few users in the back.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god.
Jeez, jeez.
Nice.
Good job.
What do we have coming up?
We have a slow Colt.
You'll Colt first.
Yeah, I got it, I got it.
Just stay in the blue.
That's all you need to know.
Super important.
They can't one tap him.
Let's see.
Oh, they're in trip support.
Yeah.
Okay, Colt first, Colt first.
We can use it defensively, just use it defensively.
Okay.
Like, against Bucky?
I'll do it for...
I'll do it after you.
Okay.
Oh, I missed my Q's.
I'm on hulk, I'm on hulk.
Ooh, ooh, I had a backup.
Or counter this one if you want to.
Counter this, counter this.
Thank you.
I'm gonna counter, I'm gonna counter.
Yeah, counter this.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, I got clapped.
Yeah.
I'm gonna try to just ult on the cloak ult.
On ours?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As long as I can.
Just get out, get out, get out.
Just don't use anything.
If possible.
Okay, I'll try to just get out.
They used like, two ults for that.
Ooh.
They used three ults.
I think it's everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We just have to retake one.
Oh, got you on him.
I can keep you up.
I can save you.
Wait, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Focus Bucky.
This guy is just throwing, yeah.
Rocket one.
Slow them.
No, I'm trying to hit the rocket.
I froze him, I froze him.
He's stunned.
Nice, nice.
I'm gonna ult down this and throw over here.
That's huge, that's huge.
Focus Hulk if you can.
Burn if you only can.
Hulk half, Hulk half.
Yeah, let's go to point.
Let's go point, yeah.
Hulk is half.
Holding this.
No!
Thor should be blinded.
Thor half.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor.
We're dead.
Okay, guys, we just have to...
Nice, good job, guys.
Healers, healers.
No, no, no, no.
Hulk's on point, Hulk's on point.
I got my point again.
Yeah, yeah.
We can play around Luno.
Just be around me.
Stun Thor.
Oh, no, I can't get to you.
I'm here.
Not even.
I froze Hulk, I froze Hulk.
I tried, I tried to get Rocket Hulk.
We still have point, we still have point.
Just stay on point.
Dang, on point.
Bucky low, Bucky low.
Show low, I'm ulting.
Oh, can't see.
Shielding you.
Yeah, I'm going outside of it.
She's low.
Not anymore.
Oh, shoot.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I couldn't.
They used ult, they used ult.
Just don't use anything.
I don't think...
We've lost both supports.
This is awkward.
Are we... are we committing to this?
We don't, you don't have support.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, actually?
Oh, yeah, commit, commit, commit, commit, commit, commit.
Use, use, use, use, use.
What?
What are you...
Oh, man.
Commit, commit to this, commit to this, commit to this.
Don't leave her, don't leave her.
Coming back, coming back, coming back.
Coming back.
I'm running back.
Just stay on my egg, stay on my egg.
Dead, dead, dead, dead, dead.
I got baby hulk.
Okay, nice.
Let's go.
Let's just get them all.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, kill him.
Just don't let him touch it.
Oh.
Nice.
Good job.
Go.
Okay, well, I think we keep doing the same thing.
Since, like, I'm kind of running solo tank over there, I'm gonna need a lot of heals, but it's working, right?
Yeah, yeah, I gave you the snowflake, so you should be invincible.
We start with ult, too, and I have it, so...
Good job, Lulu.
Thanks.
We could aggressively cloak ult this if needed.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, my first cloak ult was really bad.
That's okay, like, we didn't expect the thor to ult us off of the cloak ult.
Yeah, or I should have just stacked on top of each other.
I was, like, doing, like, a four square.
This is really, by the way, like, as long as we choke them in, right, and they can't go wide, we just spam the corners.
It's, like, crazy with this combo with the B.S.A.
Like, like, Squirrel and Moon is, like, crazy.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Quick, quick, quick, quick, quick.
Are we going straight fight?
No, no, no, right there.
Just go where XPC is.
You're really all...
I'm trying to keep you up so you can stay...
That's good.
Nice.
I actually died.
We can win this, technically.
They burnt two ults, they burnt two ults.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
I froze him.
Luna?
Luna's half, but...
Yeah, she was so far.
Thor is low, too.
When everyone's back, I can ult.
We're all back, we're all back.
I'm almost up top.
You can ult aggressively, too.
We're ulting aggressively on point.
Showdown, showdown, showdown, one more.
Hey, Luna ulted.
Leon, cloak all you needed.
Nice.
Let's get point, get Bruce, get Bruce, get Bruce.
Frozen, frozen, frozen, frozen.
Luna's gonna be alone in, like, five seconds.
Drop down to me.
Better stun, stun, stun Luna, stun Luna, stun Luna.
Luna dead, Luna dead.
No, she's behind, and now she is.
Nice, I got you.
Nice.
Thor on point.
Get Thor, get Thor, get Thor.
Oh, sorry, Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor.
I froze him, too, I froze him.
Nice.
I don't have another freeze, so if he jumps in, I can't do it.
He's jumping in.
Oh, my God, this freaking...
I'mma do it, I'mma do it, I'mma do it, I'mma do it.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Nice, thank you.
All their squishies are on the left.
I kinda had to do that to get...
Heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal.
I had to reload, I had to reload.
I was hitting, sorry.
No, you're good.
Oh, can we come on point again?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he's mini, he's mini.
Nice, nice.
We lost our King, though.
I'm here if we need to.
Him, too.
Oh, back up.
Punishable.
Oh...
It's just you, Poki.
Just stall as long as you can, if you...
Just stall.
Just keep stalling, just keep stalling.
Our Hulk's coming back, just stay on point.
Our Hulk is coming back.
I can't recontest that.
That's fine, that's fine.
Oh...
It's alright.
I can't give you an orb, excuse you.
Yeah, I'm good here.
Yeah, you got orb, you got orb.
I'm frozen.
Yep, yep, yep.
I'mma go up top so I have an angle on them.
Okay.
Yeah, I mean, they know that I'm playing main.
They're playing way back now.
They're scaring me a little bit.
You guys ready?
Yeah.
We're all here, we're all here.
You can cloak up first and meet it.
I'll do second ult.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm ulting.
I'm diving.
I'm on...
Thor, Thor half, Thor half.
Okay.
Just play on...
Play on cloak, I'll meet it.
Why am I...
I'm floating on the anti-grav.
Oh my gosh, are you kidding me?
I have to use this.
I'm on point if he heals me.
This is last fight, this is last fight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm damage boosting now.
I froze him.
No, I'm frozen, I'm frozen.
I have to reload.
Oh my god, you gotta be kidding me.
He hit me right when I...
Luna's so weak.
I'm on Luna.
Nope, she ulted.
If you guys can hold, I'll be back in five.
I'm trying.
Just don't get off point.
This is not my map.
I died.
Not my...
Do we stop healing?
It's just me.
It's just me and xQc.
But I'm gonna die here.
They can die here, they can die here.
I hate this map so much.
Dude, I got stuck in the anti-grav thing.
My bad, I was yapping but I was muted.
Oh no.
I was saying like, yeah, a lot of those squishies were just chilling alone in the back line.
I think if we just focused them or called who to focus, I think we would have won that OT moment.
I mean, yeah.
Squirtle's also tough on the second too, so.
I also think the squids need to die faster.
Yes, I agree.
This map is a lot harder for us.
It's a lot harder because we're running like AoE DPS, whatever, and there's no chokes there.
It's like all wide open.
We run the same thing, I think we're chilling.
I can go...
I could...
I could play Psylocke if...
I could play Psylocke if someone wants to play Luna.
Is there anybody I should switch to?
No...
Shut up, Senna.
Guys, we won the first map because we're holding...
I don't know, Senna.
Is there anyone you could switch to?
Senna, are you doing good?
No, girl, you're good.
I really think if you guys want to swap, go ahead.
Don't worry, team, you've got this.
Go in, go in, go in, go in, go in, go in, go in.
Wait, what?
It's left, it's actually left, it's left.
It's okay, some people don't know they're left and right.
That's okay.
Kill those tentacles ASAP.
Any heals, any heals?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, dude.
I would like to set up closer to point, if anyone doesn't mind.
We're down, Hulk, though, so...
You can...
Okay, then I might have to back up.
Oh my god, they're holding me down!
Dude, that fucking Hulk is so annoying.
Do we want to go to point, or what do we want to do here?
I think we go point.
I have ult.
I have ult too, I'm gonna...
To the left, Luna left, Luna left!
Luna!
Any heals, any heals?
Oh shit!
No, he's just punching me in the face!
It's not your fault, I was isolated.
We're down too, so we should just chill.
I think I'm gonna ult and switch.
We could run trip support, because they're running trip support.
If you guys want to swap it.
He's low here.
I'm down, I used my ult again.
Alright, I have to ult this, Rose.
You can push with this if needed.
I'm damaged.
I'm gonna save our supports real fast.
I'm just getting peeled like crazy right now.
I'm swapping, I'm swapping.
You're good, you're good.
I'm ulting off to site.
Froze storm.
Just play on site, play on site!
Luna one!
They're so low, they're so low.
I'm on you, I'm trying to save you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is last fight.
Thor one, Thor one!
Focus Thor if you can.
I got you.
I don't got you after that.
I hate the fact that I don't got you.
I froze him.
But I might be dead.
I'm gonna be dead here for the Thor.
If someone protects me, we can win this.
Someone protects me, we can win this.
Triple support.
Yeah, triple support crunch is disgusting.
Jesus.
That's just not even fun to be honest with you.
I don't even know why they're forcing that comp, it's just so boring.
I think it's because they also have like three support players.
So they just put them on what they're comfortable in.
Volker really, really wants the skins.
Oops.
It's so hard to get anything to die once they got triple support.
Yeah, I think like the only way to counter it was just to run our own triple support.
Yeah.
I mean there is ways to counter it without running it, but that's like a lot of coordination.
Oh my god.
I mean like...
Do we have to commit to five rounds?
They have two tank slayers, so...
Are you kidding me?
I mean I was willing to swap to DPS, but also like, you know, I want everyone to play what they're comfortable with.
Every two games, yeah.
And we're ranked individually?
Yo, I'm not gonna... I'm gonna say, I'm gonna say.
This matchup was imbalanced and there was a rating for us, right?
And we still made it to close, and they had to resolve down to triple support to win the game.
We won in my heart.
That would be kind of true.
True.
Did somebody say XQC stats?
Six kills and five complaints.
Oh my god.
Not wrong.
I don't know why my Discord overlay is not working, chat.
It's like...
Are we just... do we just go back to the chat call?
I don't know.
I think we just wait.
Until the other games... I think the other games are still going on, so we're just waiting.
What was I gonna say?
Magnary Strike?
Maybe.
My Discord's not regis... like it won't let me...
It keeps saying my... it can't connect to my Discord live.
Do we just wait here?
Can we run practice ones or no?
Wait, what do you mean?
Are we allowed to play practice games or no?
Well...
If you leave a quick play match, it gives you a penalty too.
Wait, what?
It does?
I'm pretty sure.
I don't know if they patched that, but it was in the last season.
And like you don't know when... you don't know when the other games end too.
But yeah...
Oh, my chat's saying now you wanna practice.
So what?
Like, do you really need practice before these?
It's fine.
I mean, this is... just use this as practice.
And now the rest of them will excel and we'll all do really fucking good.
Apparently you can leave two in a row and you should be fine.
If you leave two in a row, then they'll give you a penalty, so you could just do a quick play.
When is the next matchup?
Do you guys know?
I think we're just waiting for all the other games to end before we move on.
Oh, all of them have to end.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Toast is literally here, so we could just ask him.
He's literally in our lobby.
But yeah, no...
Are they close to finishing or not?
I was willing to swap if needed, but I also wanted everyone to play the role they were comfortable in.
But I was not playing tank.
I would never play tank.
I would rather play DPS than tank.
That's what I was like thinking when they ran triple support.
I thought about playing Psylocke just to see if I could get one of their supports down.
Wait, shrouds in this tournament?
I was like thinking about it.
I was doomed from the start.
What the fuck is that shit, bro?
I'm going against fucking shroud?
I know I could out DPS...
Shroud in any of your matches?
Shoto.
I'm sorry, Shoto.
I have no idea, but if it's ranked individually...
I think this is like a make-a-wish thing.
I was like, I know I could out DPS Shoto.
Yeah, all these trash ass players, I'll just throw them on you.
From DPS rate level wise.
There's no way.
I think XQC depended on my heals to keep him up because I had the shield flick on him.
Which it might do.
That's what I was worried about.
My entire goal was just to make sure XQC lives as a support.
If I get off support, then I'm not sure if XQC will play as confident as he was.
And then he was playing way too confident there.
You have a snowflake, but it's not invincibility.
He played so confident there.
No, but he had a snowflake.
And Luna's heals can be really far from her.
She can still heal you and stuff like that.
He played as if he had a second tank, but he did not.
He just jumped in with six people burst firing him.
And I was just like, oh man, that's awkward.
I try to freeze as much as I can.
I fumbled my freezes at first, but then my brain was fucking waking up.
It got better.
My freezes got better later as we went on.
And then I just didn't let the tanks have a good time there.
It's only after the second round I remembered how to do freezes and stuff.
But no, it was a lot closer than I thought.
Because our team was a Squirrel Girl player, one tank, and then four support players.
So honestly, we did really well for the team comp that we had.
I was just like, I don't know what's good, guys.
I legitimately was like, should we play this?
And I was just like, I don't know, I've never seen this comp before.
I don't know.
This comp is weird as hell.
If it works, it works.
We should have just played triple support, though.
Because it's boring as fuck, but if the enemy team is going to play triple support, we might as well play triple support.
Oh my god, okay, let me show you guys something.
Let's see, let me show you my...
Okay, these are custom games.
Okay, look, these don't matter because they're quick matches.
It has such a nice-looking record, too.
Literally, right here, you can tell.
Like, I stopped here on the 24th.
Right here, this is when I stopped playing.
You're right, let me... there we go.
Now, okay, we don't talk... these three was cursed as fuck.
We also gotta scroll one trick here.
But like, you can tell, right here is where I stopped playing because I was on vacation.
I was on vacation.
And then, on the 4th, I was like...
Celestial won.
Okay, this was fucked up because I had five support players on my team.
I literally had... I was already practicing for this tournament.
I was already practicing for this tournament.
This game was... my team had like five support mains.
And one of them locked in Rocket, was a Rocket one trick.
And he locked it in instantly.
So we were like, what the fuck do we do?
So, yeah, no, no.
I have like a nice record here.
But yeah, no.
I had like some fucking... okay, I'll show you guys the screen.
Okay, I was just...
Okay, I'll show you guys.
I don't know why I was getting randomly flamed by people.
But like, I won though.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll show you guys this.
My team...
Okay, so like, for one of the games I had...
One of the games I had was...
Was...
I had this EU player on my team.
And I fucked up once.
Where I accidentally stacked my support alt as Mantis.
With the invisible woman.
And I did it once.
We won the game.
But then I swapped to Loki.
And I saved us so many times.
Like for... because it was Koth.
So then I saved us like so many times.
Because I saved us from Magnetog.
I saved us from...
I saved us from like so many different scenarios.
And everything.
But then he hard focused on that one time.
That I doubled...
I like stacked his alt.
And then like...
And then we got against him.
The next time.
Like an hour later.
And then he...
And then my team won against him.
And then...
And then he said this.
I was just like...
I was healing.
Oh my god.
And then...
And then like I was playing.
I was playing with someone.
And they were on...
Like they were on their mains.
But their alt account was like...
Was higher ranked than their main account.
And...
Dude.
So I was like...
What the fuck are you talking about?
Like...
And like...
I needed you to know.
Okay.
It's fine.
Let me show you the stat for this one.
Okay.
Let me see if I can find it.
Like I was like...
Question mark?
I'm healing?
Like I was so confused.
I was like...
Why are you mad that I'm healing?
I was so confused.
I was like...
What?
I was healing.
Okay.
Let me see if I can find...
And then like...
And then we found out.
He was...
Cause he was like...
You NA people.
All you do is talk.
And...
Someone in my chat.
In my team.
Was like...
Oh you're EU.
That makes more sense now.
Like I had someone defend me.
They're like...
Bro.
Your EU can't even fucking read.
Okay.
This is the game he was like...
Freaking out about.
Okay.
So like...
Look at what support I had to deal with.
Like...
Look at what I had to deal with.
And like...
What do you...
Why EU me?
I had to keep everybody alive.
This fucker wasn't healing.
This...
So I had to keep everybody alive.
Like...
So I was just like...
Why are you so...
Like...
And then he flames me.
Oh my god.
I was just like...
Question mark?
What am I getting flamed right now?
Oh, it's time for round 2.
Okay.
But yeah.
It was crazy.
And then like...
But then he was somebody.
He was like...
He was like top 50 last season too.
I was like...
Bro, why are you so mad?
He was top 50 last season.
GG.
Good luck.
See you next round.
Bye bye.
I was just like...
What the fuck is wrong?
Okay, I'm gonna restart my Discord.
I just thought it was really funny.
I was just like...
I would get random...
No!
Okay, I had random people that were like...
Good luck in your Creator Cup tomorrow.
And everything.
And then...
They were like...
Good luck.
And then I would have other people that would just randomly flame me.
And then that guy...
That object guy...
Was like...
What's your excuse?
And I was like...
I didn't play this game in two weeks.
And he was like...
Well, I didn't either.
That's not excuse.
And I looked up his profile.
And he literally played yesterday.
The day before.
The day before that.
And I was like...
Oh, so we're lying now.
I was just like...
Wait, what do you mean?
You were literally playing almost every day.
He was like...
That's not an excuse to play like that.
I was like...
What?
Anyway, I had like three other screenshots too.
I was like...
I don't know.
It was so weird.
I had so many people congratulating me.
But then...
Wishing me good luck.
But I also had like...
A lot of people just randomly flaming me.
And I was like...
Who are you?
But we would win.
Like, my team would win though.
So I was so confused.
Because I was like...
But I'm winning.
Why am I getting randomly flamed?
Like...
But yeah, that was like...
That was yesterday.
I literally was like...
I was like...
Oh my god.
I gotta like speedrun how to play this fucking game again.
I'm now famous.
Yeah.
It was so weird.
It was actually...
I've never had such a weird grinding session.
And I grinded off stream.
I wasn't even streaming.
I was just like...
What's going on?
What the fuck?
I have to wait for the rate limit period to end.
I have like something called rate limit.
But I don't know what that is.
Apparently, my rate limit...
Well, I fucked up.
Okay.
Let me go to boogers lobby real quick.
So like my Discord is just...
Oh, it isn't working in general.
And I don't...
Like my...
The Discord bubbles just aren't working for me.
Because my Discord isn't letting me...
Yeah.
It says my rate limit resource has been reached for Discord.
I was like...
What does that mean?
What do you mean it got hit the limit?
How do I avoid that?
I guess you have to wipe me first.
How are we feeling?
Hello.
You guys look like that non-stop freeze.
Yeah, that was fun.
And thanks for target banning us.
Bro, I...
Bro, I actually...
I tried to ban second game.
Yeah.
You guys did not need the second ban.
The second ban.
You guys did not need it.
You guys have five support players.
That's my life.
On rank and in here.
Yeah, we need to invite the rest.
I don't have them added.
Oh, I don't have the others added.
Oh yeah, invite me.
Not booger.
Okay, who am I adding?
Binance, are you?
Yeah.
I got you.
Gang.
What do you guys mean?
So we can start planning, you know?
I mostly play support.
Oh, wait.
Wait, what?
You just like...
Oh, you invited...
Emily.
Oh, I can invite you back.
You got me out of my lobby.
You invited me to the lobby.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'll invite you back in.
I thought I was trying to be in your lobby.
Don't worry.
I'm sorry, booger.
Oh, you're already in.
Okay.
Oh, but I can mostly...
I can flex the DPS if needed.
We have no DPS players.
Are we sure?
Do we not?
No, we have.
We have.
Wait, who do we have?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
I can DPS, too.
If I need to.
Listen, with triple support, she's a dog.
I know.
Booger, you're such a fucker for using triple support.
You're such a...
We have to do support players.
We had five supports.
We didn't even get triple support.
Nobody forced you to play triple support.
They didn't.
They didn't want to.
Listen, I had to win against X.
I had to win against X.
This is revenge.
I had to.
If I lost that, I think I'd retire.
Like, straight up.
Can you invite me, please?
To the lobby?
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
I was going to invite you, but then I got invited.
Let me restart my Discord.
I'll be right back.
Alright, alright, alright.
Okay.
Guys, I think I fixed it.
I don't know.
I was like, it shows up after I left the team.
I'm so mad.
Did you guys see that?
It showed up after I left the team.
I'm so mad.
Actually, yeah, because I was like, oh, wait.
It's fixed.
And then, like, I'm so fucking mad.
Like, of course it shows up.
Like, of course this shows up after I left.
Like, oh, my God.
Really?
It fucking does that.
Alright, let's see if we can fix this.
I'm a little mad.
Not gonna lie.
I am a little mad right now.
Are you serious?
Like, this group fucking hates me.
It actually hates me.
Like, what are the odds that it works after I leave the group chat?
Wait, are you target banning her again?
That's so fucked.
I love it.
Let's do it.
Yeah, and then Poki was not happy, but we should do it again.
I was on her team when that happened.
That's so fucked up.
I love it.
Just so you guys know, Shroud told me that every time he sees me, he's gonna come for me and he's gonna kill me and make everyone focus me.
Oh, okay.
But, like, what if we...
Because you play Cloak, right?
So what if we put someone else on Cloak so he doesn't know?
Oh, we, like, switch it up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I also really want to win this because my arch nemesis is on the other team.
Who's your arch nemesis?
Cutie.
I'm a cutie pie.
I heard he plays... I forgot already.
Wait, Sina is a Squirrel Girl player.
Yeah, I played against her.
Yeah, yeah, she only plays Squirrel Girl.
We should ban the Squirrel Girl.
I mean, we could, yeah.
No, no, no, no.
And then you're gonna go triple support.
It's fine, it's fine.
No, I think it's fine.
I'm not scared of Squirrel Girl.
I'm not scared either.
No, it's fine.
I'm just messing.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold.
Who's on your team?
I don't know if he'll be playing tank.
Who's on their team?
He might play tank.
He plays Thor and he can play like strength and stuff.
I mean...
I think...
So we don't have to waste tank bans.
We just waste...
I think we ban Penny.
Yeah, just ban Penny here.
Is there anyone who can force Shroud to play tank?
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah, yeah.
Pretty much.
What did Shroud play last game?
Does anyone know?
Was he playing tank or DPS?
Or no one knows?
Okay.
No one knows.
I didn't play against him.
I played against Bulgur and he was a fucker.
Bulgur.
What was Mike playing last game?
What role was he playing?
I can see his history.
He was playing...
He played Adam Warlock.
Whoa!
At the very end.
Who is missing?
I don't have...
We need Shroud and who else?
Shroud's in here.
Sleepy.
Sleepy and CutiePie.
I don't have Shroud left.
Shroud played Punisher most of the game last game.
I see.
Oh, we could ban Punisher.
His Punisher's good.
His Punisher's start was good.
I can match it.
I know.
He can match it.
No guarantees though.
No guarantees.
Listen, we can't ban out all his picks.
So if we ban Penny, we can force him on tank.
Or like we can make them uncomfortable positions.
This guy anti-strats.
No, he's really good at it.
He plays too many characters.
We can't focus ban him.
We need to focus ban Poki because the crashout will be hilarious.
We have to ban Penny first because they'll protect Penny.
What will Poki play if she doesn't play Penny?
Support.
She plays support.
Yeah.
I think she plays Luna, right?
I think she was playing Luna earlier.
Okay.
No, no, she played Cloak earlier.
Was it Cloak?
No.
Yeah, it was Cloak.
Wait, Taric, what are you going to play?
Punisher?
I don't know who I'm going to play actually.
I don't know.
Because I could Rocket too.
Wait, I like that.
I'm down for Rocket or Cloak.
I could play any support.
But I think if you just play Cloak, Luna is just default good.
It's so good.
I could play Cloak or Luna or DPS.
Or play DPS, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Are we triple supporting it?
Is that what you're saying, guys?
Are you trying to make us triple support?
Is that what you're trying to say?
Okay, I'll kill.
I really don't mind killing.
I'm being serious.
Wait, wait, wait.
We can do...
Emily...
Wait, Invisible is a healer, right?
Just to make sure or no?
Yeah.
Yeah, support.
Okay.
Emily and Hannah...
Wait, DokiBird, what do you play against?
I play support, but I can flex DPS if needed.
I'm the same way too.
Should we do three heals?
I'm not tank.
Yeah, then we can literally have three heals.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's do Doki, Emily, and Hannah on heals.
Okay.
And then me DPS and then Boger play a tank.
Does that work?
I think that works.
That's basically meta.
They're going to ban Strange.
I'm going to ban Penny.
We're going to protect.
What do we protect?
I don't think we have anything that needs to be protected.
They might ban like Cloak.
Since I main it.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, yeah.
We could protect Cloak.
Who do we...
Who's lobby lead?
Because I got fucking kicked.
I'm going to be lead.
I'm lead every time.
It's when we're ready, by the way.
Whenever I pick a ban.
Yeah, you need to...
Okay, you need to...
Make sure it's pick and ban.
Sorry, Boger.
And then play...
We should pick and ban as well, probably.
No, no.
I'm EU, bro.
I'm EU.
I don't want to play in 200 ping.
Wait, are you both EU?
Nora and Boger?
Nora's also EU.
I'm EU.
Oh, shit.
Wow.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Trust me.
I trust you guys.
I actually warmed up on NA.
I trust all of you.
I've warmed up on NA servers already.
And I trust you with my life.
We can start.
Just choose a map.
Any payload map.
I don't care.
Honestly.
Payload.
I don't want to play...
What about that Spiderman one?
I like that one.
Sure.
Whatever.
I don't care.
No, actually.
Wait.
Another.
Because they have a squirrel player.
We don't want playing it.
We don't want anything that has, like, closed areas.
I don't think that's...
I don't think that's really good for Squirrel Girl.
Spiderman map?
Which one?
Pick a bad Squirrel Girl map.
Maybe I'll...
Okay, listen.
Just send it.
I don't give a shit.
Fuck it.
No.
I won't play payload.
He's just like...
No.
Poki's host.
Oh.
Does she have a change anything or no?
I don't know.
Do I need any...
I got kicked.
Oh, wait.
Can she just give you the leader?
Just pass you the leader.
Can you pass leader?
I got kicked because of a third party.
Are you hacking?
So you were hitting all my griddles somehow.
No, I just, I just...
I don't know.
I just spam the push thing a lot.
I spam the group ult a lot.
Yeah, makes sense then.
I swear to god guys, if I leave this VC and then go to another VC and then the voice stuff works again, I'm gonna freaking freak out.
I'm actually...
I'm gonna freaking freak out.
Like, how am I...
Oh my god, I don't know how I'm this unlucky.
Like, I don't know, guys.
I don't know, guys.
Why am I so unlucky?
Why?
Why is the world like this to me?
I'm gonna crash out.
This grid hates me.
Whoa, whoops, sorry.
I fucking swapped scenes accidentally.
I'm gonna try one more time and I swear to god...
I swear to god...
It's okay.
Nothing works, but it's okay.
It's not okay, but it's okay.
It's not okay.
Oh, starting?
We did it, guys.
Starting.
Nice.
Big moment.
Okay, guys.
Legendary crash out incoming.
We know what to do.
I believe in us.
Okay, here we go, guys.
Now what?
Are you gonna play Taric, by the way?
Which DPS do you play?
It's Noira, right?
Wait, wait, wait.
Binance, you're the leader.
Ban Penny.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Penny.
Done.
I'll probably play Cylocke, to be honest.
They're gonna ban Strange.
I'm gonna predict the bans.
And they're gonna protect Wolverine.
I'm actually banning Sylvia.
Oh, no.
Are they gonna ban?
I think they're crashing out.
They are crashing out.
They don't know what to do.
Uh-oh.
Time's ticking.
Yikes.
Oh, it didn't ban.
I guess they're confident.
Okay, listen.
They're protecting.
Are they gonna protect?
They may protect.
Should we protect, like, Mr. Fantastic or something?
No, we should protect.
Oh, what?
Oh, wait.
No, Poki's the leader.
I don't think she...
Oh, I don't think she knows.
Wait, just don't pick anything, then.
It's fine.
No, no, no.
Let's just type.
Well, we don't have...
I don't know what to do.
They didn't type anything.
Well, we can just delay it for as long as you can.
Well, just...
Do I pick Cloak or no?
Just protect Cloak.
Yeah, just protect Cloak.
You can't make us.
Okay, who do we ban after this?
I guess we could...
Ban Wolverine.
Wolverine?
All right.
Okay, Wolverine, Wolverine.
Oh, yeah, true, true, true.
Sykkuno.
Sykkuno on the empty, right?
Wait, Pokimane should be doing the game.
You...
Oh, wait, Poki.
They left, they left.
They want a remake.
Oh.
Wait, what?
What?
Let's go.
Poki, scratch your left.
Poki, Poki, left.
Oh, what?
Okay, I'm gonna go on their channel.
Hold on.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, my God.
We got the remake?
I guess so.
Leave game.
All right.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Are we remaking?
Yeah.
How do we leave this?
Do I have to actually leave the game?
You just hit escape and then leave game.
And then Bogor can remake.
All right.
I think we just typed it out.
Yeah, we could've just typed it out.
That's what I was saying.
I don't think they understood what I was going to say.
Now they know our strategy.
I can make the lobby.
That's funny.
I'm making the lobby again.
All right, we're back here again.
We'll restart my Discord one last time.
See my foogies fucking pop up.
I'll be right back.
All right, one last time.
I will restart you one last time.
Please.
I don't understand.
Why aren't you working?
I just want people to know who's talking.
Like...
Is that too much to ask for?
It's not working, guys.
It's...
I don't know why.
I don't know why it's not working.
Like...
Just...
God doesn't want me happy.
God just hates me.
He's just like...
If anybody can't be happy, I wish it was Doki Bird.
It's so fucked up.
It really is.
Like, this works.
I don't understand.
But this doesn't?
I call my therapist right now.
Oh my god.
Like, it looks like you're having trouble connecting to your Discord.
I'm like, yep.
Yep.
Looks like it.
Okay.
I don't...
I don't remember.
I don't know either.
It was like a shiny gold map.
Alright, there's still...
Oh, there's Loki one that we were playing.
We're still trying to figure out the map.
Yes, correct.
God just doesn't want me to have a good time.
I woke up with no voice.
Yes.
And I was just like, is today gonna be a good day today?
Here we go, let's see if they do it right.
Is today gonna be a good day today?
And then I was like, maybe today would be a good day.
Maybe.
It just says like, Discord doesn't exist for me.
That's like the weirdest shit.
It just be like, Discord doesn't...
You can't...
We can't connect to Discord.
I'm like, what do you mean?
I'm in Discord right now.
What the fuck do you mean?
I should have like, restarted my PC.
Why do they build my Invisible Woman?
No, they're targeting you, Emily.
You should be like, proud of that.
It's like an accomplishment.
They're that scared of your Invisible Woman.
Wait, yeah, that's actually a compliment.
Yeah, they're that scared of you.
But I'm terrible.
Why are you...
They're just doing this for...
No, you're not terrible on Invisible Woman.
Oh, thank you, Tarek.
You're fucking my shit up.
But what are you gonna...
What's your next go-to?
I mean, I play either Luna or Mantis or Cloak.
All right, we're...
I can play Squirrel Girl.
You can play...
You can play whatever support.
You can play five different characters.
But they picked Wolverine.
They protected...
Yeah, because Sykkuno plays Wolverine.
Oh, we'll see what they ban, I guess.
I mean, we could ban Luna.
What do you play, Doki?
I play any support.
Not just a Luna one trick, what the fuck?
I know, I know, I know.
I never said that.
You would ban like...
We can ban Starlord or...
Storm?
Shroud plays a lot of Storm.
Yeah, ban Storm, ban Storm, ban Storm, ban Storm.
Fuck it, send it.
Okay.
The only issue is that we can't...
The only biggest issue, we can't get rid of flankers.
Because Invisible Woman and Luna is banned.
Wait, should we do Raccoon Punisher or not really?
We could do...
I could always...
You can do that.
Or should I just play...
I'm down for either.
Okay.
If you want to play Rocket, I could play Mantis and then we'll try to sleep the flankers.
Or I'll try to sleep...
Yeah.
I'm gonna play Rocket.
I'll play Mantis and I'll try to sleep the Wolverine then.
Okay, guys.
I don't have a lot of experience on Rocket, but I'm gonna be right.
Don't worry, people will know how to play Rocket.
Just stick to Punisher and make sure your beacons are always down.
Listen, Tariq.
Everything lies on you, okay?
They're gonna have Wolverine, you need to shoot that guy.
I'm sorry, what did you say?
You need to shoot the Wolverine.
Shoot the Wolverine?
Lol gag.
I'm gonna be fighting demons the entire game, bro.
Yeah, the Wolverine's gonna be annoying.
We gotta make sure...
We're gonna have to make sure to pour a lot of resources to Bogre if he gets caught by Wolverine.
I'm gonna save my bubble for him.
I won't get caught, it's crazy.
Oh, good.
Do you wanna call when you want infinite ammo?
I can, but if there's good corners, I think around the corners are good.
Oh, you should be up here.
I can call it, but if you want a place that you can too.
I'll just ask every now and then.
Okay.
That guy's low in the front, is he getting healed?
The fuck?
Let me know if you guys see Wolverine, okay?
Just let me know and I'll turn.
Oh, did they kill the beacon?
Whoops.
Yeah, you wanna like put it at a site kind of?
Yeah, push him, push him.
Oh, I'm stunned, I'm stunned.
I'm okay, yeah, I'm okay.
It's like, I'm gonna pass it.
I could as well.
Got one.
Damage boost to you?
He's going to my right, is he?
It's a clone, they'll pass it.
He's behind the cart, uh, the Wolverine.
That's fine, he missed his, he missed his grab.
What's the?
Right side, right side, look your right side.
Just so I know.
Can we kill clones as well?
Wolverine's top, top left.
I have damage boost to you.
Can we ult this or no?
We don't have anything.
I died, oh my god.
Do we have any ults for support?
Not yet.
Okay, I'm 73 right now.
Stay with me, play with me.
Can we get back in?
I damage boost to you.
I'm ulting in now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, play, play, play.
I damage boost to you.
Do you have bubble?
Uh-oh.
Yeah, bubble, bubble her.
I got you.
Thank you.
I have, uh, I'll be healing you guys, I'm ulting.
Get in the blue, get in the blue, you're fine.
All right, I got you.
Your damage, damage boosted?
Oh my god, I haven't played fucking Mantis in so long.
Yeah, I couldn't do anything, sorry.
I'm rezzed, I'm rezzed, I'm rezzed.
That's good.
Okay, Doki, you have your ult?
Yeah, we're gonna have a Warren ult.
Okay, watch out.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Play slow, play slow, play slow.
Watch out, he's stuck.
97, 97, 97.
I'll be back soon, I'll be back soon right now.
So scary.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Ready?
Shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, shoot the squirt.
I'm shooting it, I'm shooting it, I'm shooting it, I'm shooting it.
It's down, it's down.
I'm getting fucked.
I'm ulting you, I'm ulting you.
There you go.
Push this, push this, push this.
That's huge.
You're crazy.
We're going to the back.
I blinded him, I blinded him.
I can't get to you, Ogre.
They're going on me.
I got you, I got you.
He's low.
Shoot him, shoot him.
We're good.
Are they all good?
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
Damage boosting.
I'm going to take a bunch of damage.
I need to stay back a little bit.
Yeah, we need your root for sure.
Don't get one-shot, Luchette.
I'm safe here.
Oh, Carro, come on, Carro, Carro, Carro.
I'm getting fucked.
Back me up.
I slept Mag, I slept Mag, I slept Mag.
I got one-shot.
I'm trying to get to you, Blue.
I got one of them, guys.
I got the Blue Marines.
We have to...
I'm on my way back.
I'm pushing out, I'm pushing out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No Blue Marine right now.
You guys can do it.
I'm trying to kill that Taric, trying to kill that here.
I can't get it, I'm right here.
Can't leave.
Oh, they're just not getting it.
I'm right here, I'm here.
I'm gonna back up, I have ult.
Whoa.
Fuck, I should have backed up.
Yeah, we should have got out of that corner.
Like, go out the other way.
Yeah, yeah, don't go into the corners, guys.
Oh, shit.
Should be fine.
Helper.
Here, I got you.
I'm here, I'm here.
Blue Marine on me, I'm good.
I got you, I got you.
They bubbled, they already bubbled.
They don't have bubble.
Yeah, I'm pocketing you, I'm pocketing you.
Yeah, we're both pocketing.
We're in the corner.
We're pocketing you hard.
Push, push, man, man, man, man.
I'm up.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Here, here.
High ground.
Oh, there's a Wolverine.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
You're safe, you're safe, you're safe.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Oh, we double support ulted, that's my bad.
Oh, shit.
We gotta get this fight because we have to double support ulted.
You can kill Wolverine, kill Wolverine.
I don't see him, I don't see him, I don't see him.
Yeah, we're down three.
I didn't see Wolverine, sorry, I was too much going on.
It's okay, it's okay.
You guys can reset.
I almost killed like three of them.
Can you live or no?
I'm gonna get a res here.
No, you're fine.
Oh, you have a penta, you're fine.
I'm gonna get a res.
Here, here, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I shouldn't have gone out, sorry.
Yeah.
We might need Nora to maybe go on the Hawkeye.
Okay, yeah, I can do that.
Damage boosting you.
I'm going into the...
I'm just going to pocket you for now, over here.
Oh, Taric, don't!
Don't do that!
He's a weird.
I'm getting cooked.
I fucked him, so I'm gonna die for it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you won this.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm low.
I don't think I can get...
I'm healing you.
I'm just gonna, I'm gonna play low-key.
We kinda just have to walk out.
Pugra's the only one on point.
I think we swap the rat.
I think we swap the rat and Punisher.
I don't be real with you guys.
You use Punisher ult, and we get...
Yeah, I don't think, yeah.
TP, TP, TP for spawn, TP for spawn.
Over in spawn.
You want me to play something else, or?
Yeah, yeah, swap, swap, swap.
I can swap as well if we need me to swap.
Yeah, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's good, it's good.
I'm like, not in the, I'm, I'm at a wrong spawn.
What the fuck am I?
You, uh, yeah.
He's gonna, I don't think he's gonna live.
You can go in the spawn room, I hit G, right?
Yeah, but he's, he, the timing was off already.
Yeah, I died earlier.
I'm gonna be late as fuck.
It's fine.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Thanks for the bubble.
I'm grabbed.
I gave you invuln, I'll give you invuln here.
Kiting, kiting.
Can we match?
I'll team back in 3, 2, 1.
I'll team back.
I don't, no!
I don't have ult here.
I'm dead, I'm dead, he didn't hit me, he didn't hit me.
I have my ult too.
This Hawkeye is coming for me.
Yeah, I'm not dead at all, I'm coming.
Oh, I can't.
I'm not grouped right now.
Can we get out or no?
I got him.
That's fine, that's fine.
Magneto's dead.
Watch out, the Hawkeye ult.
We're getting one.
I need, I need, I need someone to peek.
Oh, I couldn't.
I couldn't support ult there.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I need to clone somebody.
Okay, I'm not gonna lie, I felt like I wasn't a part of half of our teamfights there.
But also, the choke point, that little hole choke point is so hard to get out of.
Like, I don't know if you guys know what I'm talking, anyway, fuck it.
We need to counter Hawkeye.
I can kill the Hawkeye, I can kill him way easier.
Okay, that sounds good.
It'll be good with Loki too.
Okay.
Do we still want to triple support?
Let's try this.
Yeah, it's real support.
Okay, Dyrone, you have to do all the work.
Okay.
I'm gonna punch his ass.
Wait, were you playing Hella?
Sorry, I didn't know I took it.
No, no, you're chilling.
Yeah, go Hella.
I just literally swapped at the very end.
Nori, do you play tank?
I play...
The only tank I play is...
Groot.
Yeah, I didn't think I was gonna be good against him.
Nah, it's fine.
Yeah, Groot is way too farmable against that.
Yeah.
I could go Hawkeye, Loki.
You can, do it.
We just need to deal with Childe, guys.
We think that was kind of whatever.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, are you guys okay?
One shot on my ass.
Yeah.
Are you guys okay?
We're just consistent.
I'm with Mike, Mike, Mike.
We gotta help both.
Hawkeye's one-shot.
I'm with Mike, Mike, Mike.
He's still low.
Any heals here?
Got you, got you.
One shot again.
Okay.
Our comms are ducking down.
We have to reset.
We're not comming anymore either.
Let's do a team push here.
Boger, take over.
Boger, as the highest ranked player, you should be ideal.
I'm just kidding.
Yeah, I can't even get put clone on you.
The demons are after me, guys.
This game.
I might have to ult in here.
I can ult now.
I have ult.
Yeah, we can't push up at all.
That's the issue.
Listen, guys, we need to make some swaps.
We need something diveable.
Do you play something diveable, Taric?
Do you play dive characters?
I don't have a dive character.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll just go back to Punisher.
I think Punisher is better.
He might just support ult to push up.
I think we have to.
We just need to support ult to push up on this.
Because we got a kill now.
I'm doing it.
Oh my god.
Nice, nice.
That's huge.
Focus the mag.
I'm just gonna stab him.
Maybe we let him live a little bit.
There you go.
They didn't.
They did not use any support ults.
Okay, that might be GG for us.
No, I have my ult.
I have mine too.
Where's our cloak?
Okay.
We're just gonna be back here.
I killed Trap.
Wolverine.
Where are you?
Okay, you're here.
Alright.
I'm one.
Oh, we're dead.
I'm dead.
Just be on my ult.
I'll be on my ult.
Nice, nice.
We're even.
I need heals in back.
Play point.
Support, support.
Here we go.
I'm ulting.
There's a Hawkeye on our backline.
Last play here.
I thought I was gonna support ult.
Can I try DPS?
No, I don't think so.
I think we still DPS.
I'm down.
My Dino's half.
Am I jumping into his bullets?
Oh my god.
Are you guys okay?
I'm chilling.
I'm touching point, fighting DPS.
I'm point.
I'm trying to.
There's 20 people in front of me.
I think it's over.
You kinda shit on me, I'm not gonna lie.
Taric, Taric, Taric, buddy.
We need you to lock in.
Dude, but I'm not...
I just realized...
Listen, listen.
I have to play.
You're going on Groot, bro.
I wanna try DPS.
Okay, I'm down, I'm down.
Can we protect Invisible Woman if possible?
We can.
Yeah, we can.
Their first ban would be Invisible Woman.
Maybe they won't first ban it again, you know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I also play DPS if needed.
But like, my best DPS is Psylocke.
Healers need to help each other.
Yeah.
I can't.
The thing is, he's playing Hawkeye.
You can't do anything against a...
You can't do anything against headshots.
A healer can't heal a one-shot.
So then I was like...
Am I getting my DPS?
I don't know, I'm just being flexible.
In general.
I'm just being incredibly flexible.
I think these are gonna...
It's just RNG randomized.
It's just like...
RNG randomized.
I think like...
I just got like...
It's just unfortunate because like...
There's a lot of support players.
I'm trying to be as flexible as I can.
Hawkeye's not that strong in higher ELO.
But when you have one tank player...
It's really hard.
It's so easy against...
If you have one tank player...
Hawkeye can farm so easily...
Against us because of it.
Yeah, so like...
All they have to do is just dive our...
Our single tank.
And he can't do anything about it.
Like I'm willing to flex anything...
But a tank.
If I put on a tank, I'm just gonna fucking...
I'm just feeding.
You can't target Brand's Shroud.
He's flexible on...
He has a lot of flexibility on DPS.
It's just target Brand...
Is like best DPS.
So we don't have to deal with that shit.
I'm just...
I'm just trying my best.
Honestly, you can.
You just need some damage.
That's not Taric dying off cooldown.
He plays Starlord.
He plays Storm.
He plays Hawkeye.
He plays Hella.
I mean, nothing different.
I don't like playing tank.
It's not fun.
Tank is not fun.
I wanna play DPS right now.
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't know.
What map?
Didn't you choose a map?
I'm just waiting for the bathroom to be back, guys.
Guys, we can do this.
We could.
We can.
I have a crazy plan here that will be really stupid.
What if we go 3 tanks, 3 supports?
Whatever it takes.
Is it just because you don't want Taric to die?
I give up.
You guys do whatever you think is best.
I play a really good...
Groot DPS.
DPS Groot.
What map do we play, guys?
I need to just choose something.
Any favorite maps?
Any good picks here?
I'll just pick something.
I'm back.
I might just cleanse myself after this by playing rank.
It's just like...
It's unfortunate because the thing about my row is that I'm the only support.
I'm in the same tier as Shroud.
I'm on the same tier as Shroud for the row for people.
So I feel like...
I feel really bad.
I feel really bad because tier-wise, I'm like...
being put in the same skill range as Shroud.
And obviously, since he's a DPS player...
As a support player, I'm sorry.
I can't match that.
So I feel bad because then I'm...
They got Shroud and then this team got me.
He called you European.
You're gonna take that?
You're gonna take that shit?
Personally, I wouldn't.
But that's just me.
Also, we actually didn't pick first map.
I was just saying.
They started it, remember?
True.
We probably just didn't know how to pick it.
And then we just picked the same one.
That's true.
Again?
It doesn't matter!
Just let us play!
Please!
I just wanna play.
Dude, I bet you everyone's gonna be waiting for us just watching our game.
I think they're probably all done already.
Just type it out.
Just tell them to type it out.
They don't have to remake it.
Or is it because they want to play another map?
Okay, good talk.
He's saying Koth.
That's it, I'm playing Koth.
Okay, it's remake time.
I'm leaving.
Alright, time to remake.
What a fucked up day.
I still don't have my Discord overlay.
Oh, you know what?
I was so sad.
When I got home, there was snow.
I was like, Yippee!
I'm leaving Seporo!
I don't have to deal with snow anymore.
And then I arrived, and I saw snow on the airfield.
I was like, what a fucked up day.
That was...
No, they're gonna change it later.
Yeah, you have a long time before we actually start.
Maybe we're gonna restart another lobby too.
Yeah, the snow was so rough.
I was tired.
I was like, I can't wait to not see snow.
And then I saw snow, and I was like, what a fucked up day.
I did talk a little bit about the trip.
I did talk a little bit.
The trip was...
It was fun.
Sorry, my brain is so fried right now.
I'm sick.
I caught a cold on the last day.
I'm surprised I was able to rank up as much as I did last night, because I was playing sick as well.
Technically, I'm sick right now as well.
I caught a cold on literally the day I leave.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I was like, oh my god.
Everything is not going for doki.
I survived.
I survived for so long until literally the last day.
Everyone was sick.
I heard a lot of players were sick.
A lot of coaches and staff were sick.
The audience members were sick.
It was...
I woke up on the last day and I was like...
I can't play the game.
Half my heroes are just blocked.
We can ban Hawkeye as well.
It came back and I'm blowing my nose.
I literally had no voice when I woke up today.
I could not talk today when I woke up.
I had to make some warm tea.
I had to make some warm tea and get the Chinese medicine.
That's like blackish.
While you guys are comfortable, I'll just flex.
But not on tank.
I fucking hate tank.
I'm sorry, Bulger.
It's okay.
I get it.
Taric, listen.
I chose this map because it's one of the best group maps.
Do not disappoint me, okay?
Okay.
I can't hear him.
Hello?
Voices?
I think he chose to ignore you.
You gotta pick up your IGL or he's not gonna acknowledge you.
I can't.
I can't IGL.
Taric.
I can't.
I can't IGL.
Then say it during the match.
Don't say it after.
Don't be a hindsight Harry.
You hear me?
I fucking hate hindsight Harry.
Say Taric stop dying so early.
What the fuck are you doing?
I know after I'm dying early, dude.
I know.
I agree.
But during the moment, I'm just playing.
Guys, we're a team.
We're not fucking team.
Come on, guys.
We're a team.
He's out.
He's never gonna see Bogre again.
I'm not actually blaming you, Taric.
I was doing it for views.
Let's focus up here.
Focus up here.
Taric.
Alright.
Let's count his deaths, guys.
Bogre, you bought us, right?
What the hell?
It's not for you guys.
Okay.
Damn, we gotta kill them.
I'm dead.
You're so alive.
You're so healthy.
Look at you go.
We have lamps here in the back.
I'm crushing.
Mag low.
I'm on.
I'm trying my best to keep you up.
I need heals too.
Wait, Taric.
We gotta kill here.
Heal me up.
I need juice.
I need heals too in the back here.
We're getting up.
I might have to swap.
Maybe we go inside here with a group.
Come left.
Okay, nice.
Come inside.
Kill him, badumais.
Give me the ult.
Wait.
Oh, I'm dead, boy.
All good.
We can invis ult first.
Okay, I'll ult.
We can invisible woman ult every ult in the game, basically.
Where exactly do you want me to ult?
On site?
You gotta be able to shield her with invisible woman though because that Mag's gonna fucking chuck the rock at her.
I'm taking a lot of damage from them here.
Ike, she's coming.
You watch me.
Yeah, we're playing this.
Alright, here we go.
Watch out, he's gonna go in any second now.
I can shield this.
Nice, shoot it.
Shoot it.
I'm done.
Kill the thing.
It's fine.
I got you.
I'm gonna ult in here.
We got one.
Nice.
I'm gonna go in with this.
I have to go in with this.
Play with me.
I'm not good at all.
I'm coming.
I need a little health here.
I can't keep you up.
I think we play back now.
Everyone's dead.
We have to play a point this last second.
You're right.
It might be cocked.
It might just be Jover.
Oh.
Can you get back in or no?
I'm heading over.
Emily has to touch this.
Nice try.
It's fine.
I think next one's gonna be better.
That one felt worse.
I'm not gonna lie.
You can swap.
You don't have to play Groot.
Just play whatever.
It doesn't matter.
No, I BurgerEye tilted you.
I'm sorry, bro.
No, I'm not tilted.
I was just playing with you.
It's 4 AM.
I'm not tilted.
I was just playing with you, bro.
I was bantering.
I didn't know if you were upset or not.
Oh, no, Burger.
You can't be tired.
I have you as my teammate against you.
Okay, listen.
I'll be completely honest, guys.
Look in.
That's my call.
I got you.
You can play Hella if you want.
No, we're good like this.
You're good.
Just to be clear, it was my chat that tilted me.
I wasn't tilted.
Wait, you hate your chat?
That's fucked up.
Oh my god, you hate your chat?
Oh my god.
He hates you.
Remember that.
And you're gonna still give him money.
Where they at?
We stay up.
I'm gonna drop, actually.
I'm gonna poke them here.
But you stay up.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
Not nice.
They got us real good.
We're not there.
We're not there at all.
Nice.
Nice, Burger.
Thank you, Burger.
Heal Burger.
I'm healing.
I'm dying here, but I'm healing.
I'm coming.
I dropped down.
Are you alive?
Oh no, we don't have heal supports now.
Penny one, penny one.
We're coming, we're coming.
I'm gonna drop C for you, Taric.
I'm coming back.
No one has point yet.
Did you rez?
No, I didn't rez.
We gotta shoot that if we can.
I can't shoot that.
Let's regroup.
I think we're split up right now.
I'll just pretend to be a clone.
They'll never know.
Mhm.
I have rocket ult.
I'm scaling, I'm scaling.
Move up together, move up together.
They're gonna go in.
I'm pushing this, I'm pushing.
They're all low, they're all low.
Okay, I got involved.
Yeah, push this up.
Push, push.
I'm not gonna use ult yet.
Ducky, we need it in a bit.
Yeah, where's the invisible boy, man?
I need help, I need help.
In the backline, I got you.
Playing that, playing that.
Kill squirrel, squirrel, squirrel.
In the front, guys.
They're all over there.
I'm low, I'm low on the right.
I'm low on the right.
No, I'm not.
I'm coming back with ult.
Nice kill.
I'm coming back, map change, map change.
We have a rescue team.
Mag's low, mag's low.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I'm shielding you.
Yeah, I'm healing you.
Penny on me.
I'm dying here.
I give you invuln, I give you invuln here.
Penny low, penny half.
That's huge, that's huge, that's huge.
I'm trying to keep you up right now.
Reloading here.
I can't.
I'm low, I'm low in the backline.
Squirrel low.
I got one, squirrel low.
You're up two, you're up two right now.
Strange, strange.
Strange low, strange low.
Strange low, dead.
Penny above.
I cannot help.
Penny's on me, penny on me.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I have invuln here, but...
Penny one, penny one.
I'm gonna die, I think.
I'm dead.
But I can't get on point.
They had the point that whole time.
Yeah.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's my fault, guys.
It's not your fault, man.
I don't feel bad, dude.
It's my fault, guys.
I'll do better next time.
I hope so, because I'm still on your team.
At least Tariq won't be on our team.
Listen, I will take responsibility, I will take responsibility for these losses.
And that's okay, and that's okay.
Hey, at least we had fun, right guys?
No.
He said it, not me, bro.
He said it, not me.
He's here to win the skins, Tariq.
We're just here to vibe.
I need the skins badly.
I need the skins, I need the skins.
I'm addicted.
I need them.
He was an Overwatch streamer, he really needs the skins.
I love skins, I love skins.
Alright, guys.
We're still playing.
I felt like I was fucking fighting my life with 1 HP all the time.
I felt like I had to heal.
Tariq, we're playing against you next game, but your team is stacked.
I'll be honest with you.
Oh, we're gonna fuck you.
Bro, you have Shroud, you have Shroud, X, and Selene.
And we're not gonna hold back either.
Were you sandbagging this?
Yeah.
I was setting myself up for this.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, it's been...
Guys, I just need you to know, the next three games...
Tariq, Mike said you're scared.
Mostly support players as well.
I'm not scared of him, dude.
I 1v1 him on that one.
He said you're scared.
He came in here, he said, Tariq's scared.
Scared of what?
We're in for a ride.
Trust me, I'm not scared.
Check how many times I died.
Alright, I'm checking.
That's what I'm saying.
It's been a fucked up month.
My RNG has been actually the worst it's ever been.
Guys, the moment...
I think...
The year of the sneak has not started well for me.
Good luck, good luck, good luck.
Doki, doki, doki.
The year of the sneak has not been great.
Buck 50 with your doki, we're not winning the last game.
I know, I know.
I'm not winning the next three matches, I know.
I've already accepted that.
We're so fucked.
Next one is fucked for all of us.
Next one is Hydrogen Bomb vs Koffing Baby.
Wait, can I play DPS then?
If it's fucked.
Wait, do we have...
I think we have DPS players.
We have DPS players?
I mean, we have Nora.
Nora plays DPS.
Yeah, I'm alright.
I'm so cooked.
What if I go DPS?
Poker, we have no tank players.
You're literally our only tank.
Listen, it doesn't matter if I have a tank player.
If I have Taric dying off cooldown, I'll be real.
Yeah, but Taric has Shroud.
He doesn't fucking need...
He'll just be like the second person.
If Taric dies, Shroud just clones himself.
We're all so low.
I've like accepted it when I saw my matchups.
I was like, maybe it won't be that bad.
I was like, oh my god.
Maybe we can do it with all these support players.
Doki, Doki, Nora, Nora, Nora.
Oopsie.
You're on a team with Sleepy?
Yeah, but Sleepy is also a support player, guys.
Guys, I'm a loser.
We also have a team full of support players.
Can we ban Penny next?
Oh, 1-1?
You want to ban Penny with the two Penny mains on your team?
Wait, what?
Oh yeah, Poki, I'll just bring this out here.
Burger's idea too long.
It wasn't my idea.
Okay, it was my idea.
I'll be honest.
I won't lie.
Yeah, it was his idea.
We told him not to do it.
That's fucked up, man.
I heard Burger's the sweatiest player here.
He's literally commanding people like he's a fucking general.
Oh no, he crashed out last game.
Don't worry.
I can't comment.
Okay, listen.
That was uncommandable.
I'll be honest.
Taric yelled at him and then he crashed out.
No, that's fucking crazy.
You're not Burger.
What did I just add?
I'm not Burger.
He's not Burger.
What's your name in game?
Not Burger.
Oh, I added someone else.
Oh, yeah, you added a random Burger.
Oh no.
That's why after this tournament I might play some more.
I might play like one or two ranked games.
Actually, I don't want to do solo though.
I already had a fucked up session.
I don't know.
I was already like I need a...
One or two.
Oh my god, did I miss something?
I'm sorry, I was getting food.
Oh, yeah, Poki, you missed something.
What's up?
We were against you last round, right?
Mm-hmm.
Burger was the one that demanded we ban Penny.
That's true.
I know.
Yeah, we tried to stop him.
It was so fucked up.
Because I faced him first game and he did the same.
Listen, I'm here to win, Poki.
I don't want to listen to you.
You can't blame me.
I'm here to win, Poki.
Wait, I thought this was a fun event.
No, it's not.
I have fun winning.
Oh, no.
By the way, Booger does not believe in us for this matchup.
There's no peace.
I banned Penny because I thought it was the right choice.
He doesn't believe in us?
No, he was like...
He literally was like...
We're not winning this next one.
I believe in you guys.
I'm just saying it might be slightly difficult to win this game.
Yeah, he's already given up.
We can though.
I believe we can win.
Wait, Poki, where are you?
Because they have a better tank player than us.
No, I understand.
Nah, it's cool.
It's not a big deal.
I'm crashing out.
Yeah, no weak mental.
We can do it.
What's our strats?
We're gonna be concerned.
We're gonna be concerned about The Shroud.
The Shroud just wrote Taric last game.
I'm gonna be honest.
Who is Ni Hao?
Do I need to kick this person?
No, they're...
I don't remember who they were but they were tank on the last game.
Yeah, but are they on the enemy team?
Yeah, they are on the enemy team.
No, are they now on the enemy team?
Isn't that Qtpie?
Yeah, I think we removed Qtpie.
Yeah, he is on their team.
Wait, is he?
No, he's not.
You should kick him.
Goodbye Qt.
But like, if I'm wrong, I'm so sorry.
You look like the bad guy.
You are the bad guy.
It wasn't me.
I mean, he is the leader at the lobby so everybody can just blame him.
BogrNation.
Hi, Bogr, lead us.
What do we do?
Okay, I think we ban Groot 100%.
I just don't want to play against Groot.
I know what they are going to protect next.
What do we play?
We play Penny.
We play support.
We have a lot of support players, no?
No, no one plays DPS.
I can play anything, though.
I think we have a lot of DPS players.
Yeah, okay, we have two Penny players.
So you guys have to decide who is going to play Penny.
Wait, I don't really want to play Penny.
Oh, you don't want to play MrFantastic, though?
Honestly, listen, we need to...
I think it might work.
Here is what I told my team last game.
Give me one life with MrFantastic.
And when I die, I'll switch off.
And we'll play Triple Healer.
Yeah, so Doki plays support.
Lulu, are you a support player?
I can do support or DPS.
I think we need you on support, probably.
Who do you need on support?
Doki, you are a support.
I'll be on support, Jill.
Support Jill?
It's a luxury to play support in this game.
I can bust out the Punisher, or Moon Knight, or Namor.
Oh.
Guys, I wanted to play DPS.
So, Namor is DPS.
And then we have minimum one more DPS.
I'm on support, Jill, because you're like...
You're the highest-ranked support.
I don't care.
You want to random it?
Something Penny is good on.
The spooky map.
The vampire map?
I know it.
Midtown, right?
Midtown, Midtown.
The one with the little choke at the beginning.
This one, right?
Not the new one.
The vampire map.
Not the new one, no.
What spooky map?
I know which one.
Booger is already suffering.
You can't leave him like this.
That's true.
No, no, no.
He's not having a good time.
What the fuck is this?
Venom map.
Yeah, this is the Venom map.
The symbiote map.
Glintar.
Booger and I are both in tank and support, Jill.
Because he's like...
I don't know what else to say.
Okay, I'm just kidding.
Who needs me to keep him alive?
This is the same of XTC.
He's like, no, you don't swap out support.
I was just like, okay.
It's not Glintar, for sure.
The Tokyo map?
Maybe.
This one?
No.
Is it the Spidey map?
Yes.
Spidey map.
Definitely Spidey map.
Is that the symbiotic surface?
This is what you get from me.
You have to capture a point first.
And then you get the card.
It's just the payload one.
Just the payload.
This one.
The payload spider map.
Wait, she means symbiotic surface.
You were right.
Guys...
It's all good.
It's really hard to describe the map.
That's why I call it goopy map.
Spidey map.
Not Glintar.
Girl spider in the beginning that goes like...
Yo, it's this way.
The one we played against you today, Poki?
In the scrims?
Were you played?
No.
We haven't played it today.
Nope.
We can't be losing the map select, guys.
This is embarrassing.
Lulu, we played it earlier.
The one we drawed on?
No, not the one we drawed on.
The one we smacked on.
I'm starting.
The symbiote.
I can't believe...
Guys, wow.
Yes, this one.
It's this one.
I can't.
It is this one.
I don't care.
Pick whatever map.
We know our fate.
We're against Shroud and Taric.
Whatever map...
We make our grave.
She's doomed.
I'll try my best.
What do you like to play second and third?
I usually play...
Support or Mr.Fantastic.
Unironically.
Protect Pantheon.
I'm dooming.
I'm gonna fuck out my Doomer.
But I'll still play my best.
I might be dooming.
But I'll still do my best.
You're Penny for sure.
It's fine.
Can someone...
What are we banning?
Surprise me.
There's nothing I can ban.
There's nothing you can really...
We need someone who can take care of Storm.
Not gonna lie.
Storm?
I agree.
Shroud is gonna Storm.
The only issue...
They're really just using the fact that we have very...
A lack of support ults.
Defensive ults for their attacks.
I'll just flex whatever support...
The other support player wants to play.
Is it possible to two heal with this?
We can two heal.
This is gonna be really fucking scary.
But yeah.
You got the healing.
I got the DPS.
Good work.
What do we do against Storm?
We burn her.
Do you want a third support?
Or do you want me to go punish her?
Go punish her.
We don't punish her.
We need a rocket.
Mmm.
I don't think we can.
I'll be honest with you.
I don't think we're gonna get Vladimir.
You wanna learn rocket?
I'd rather fucking cut off my hands.
It's so easy.
I'd rather cut off my hands than play rocket.
Don't I just press right click like this?
When I'm in my turret...
Don't drop the infinite ammo.
I'll call for infinite.
At this corner you can drop it.
Around this corner.
Drop it.
Oh my.
Nice.
Go punish her.
I'm on it.
Okay we don't have...
Good job.
Careful because...
I'm solo healing.
Careful.
Widow half up top.
Widow 25 HP.
Yep.
I'm healing now.
I pushed him.
I pulled him to us.
Strange in the half.
Strange is by himself.
1 HP on Widow.
Whenever you have infinite again drop it.
Dropping.
Thank you.
Push him up.
Strange.
Backing.
We're just spamming heals on you.
Thank you for spamming.
I have all here.
I'm going to push up with this.
Okay.
I'm pushing up.
Go up.
I'm on Widow.
Can I ulti here?
That's good.
Nevermind.
We got a burner.
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
I'm dead here.
I'm dead here too.
I'm alive.
Punisher.
You have Raccoon.
I'm giving you infinite ammo now.
Ult this.
Nevermind.
Don't ult this.
We can ult this actually.
Bulgar is going in with his ult.
I'm waiting.
He missed.
Ult this when you can.
We're out.
Holy fuck.
Chill.
Strange is looking for an ult probably.
He used it.
Get him.
Wait.
You have Resguard.
Did you ever use it?
Yeah.
I didn't know you did.
I broke it.
I broke it to move it up.
I just got it down.
You're alone.
We need to regroup here.
Oh, I'm muted.
Fuck.
Yo, just yell at me next time.
I thought you were super focused.
It's okay.
This is going well.
I thought you were locked in.
I was super muted.
We can go in with...
Raccoon ult.
Yeah.
I'm waiting.
Okay.
We can.
I'm dead here.
I'm looking for...
I'm dead.
Yeah.
We just have to reset.
They all ulted.
Yeah.
Okay, guys.
I have my ult.
Okay.
I'm 79.
I think...
We need your ult for Punisher ult.
We've been holding on to Raccoon ult.
I need heals and choke.
We need to use Raccoon ult.
Can you give me...
Oh, you did.
Okay.
He has it again.
That's insane.
Oh, wait.
Actually, we have to go in with this.
I can't.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't realize.
Okay.
I'm in.
Oh, I need...
Oh.
No.
I would've killed the Raccoon if he didn't use that ult.
I'm on it for you.
I'm on it.
I'm dead.
I'm coming back.
Can we...
I'm literally throwing.
I'm so sorry.
Don't worry about it.
Don't think about it, Nora.
It's fine.
It's not that...
It's a 4-5 tournament for skins.
Listen, if anyone feels bad about their performance, it doesn't matter.
We're not playing fucking finals of...
whatever their final thing is.
We're playing Apex Legends finals.
It doesn't matter.
That's what I mean.
Lock in.
We can still win.
Okay.
I actually think we need a shield tank with Penny here to lower the damage.
I could play...
Magneto if you'd like.
I think Penny's better.
Do you not want to play Strange?
I can play Strange, but I feel like I'm just gonna eat shit by their Punisher and Storm.
I'll play Loki.
Even then, my Invo's gonna do jack shit against their Storm.
I do think if we calm a lot...
I mean, the defense is probably better.
Do you want to play Loki or Sue?
I think you go Sue because you can't copy Raccoon.
That's true.
Yeah.
So you kind of need Sue.
Do you have your Res Beacon down?
Yeah, it's up top.
We could try and trip support if...
here...
If we die early and it's not working, just run a triple support and see how it goes.
They know, you know?
Like when our DPS gets swapped to a third support.
Infinite ammo whenever.
Dropping.
Thank you.
Strange tanking a lot here on the side.
Let me turret down.
Magic Ankh.
The Ankh, the Ankh.
I have ulti, I have ulti.
Yeah, do it, do it, do it.
Yeah, I'm ulti.
Strange one.
Strange is one.
He followed me.
I have ult, though, here.
Yeah, we can win this.
The ult is on point, the ult is on point.
Looking at Strange.
We have no defensive ult, though.
Help me, Vermeer, help me for this.
I don't have push, I don't have push anymore.
Are you good there?
I think they have Moon Knight, though.
They have Moon Knight, oh, and they have Strange ult.
I'm gonna ult.
I couldn't, I got Moon Knighted.
I'm giving you infinite ammo.
I got Moon Knighted.
Yeah, watch out Strange ult.
He's going in, guys.
Oh, he just walked on you, man.
I'm coming over.
I'm pushing up here, guys.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm not gonna do anything.
I got blocked by Storm.
We have too many DPS ults.
We don't have enough support ults.
It's kind of rough.
Listen, guys, one more map here.
Don't worry about it.
Bogr, be our leader.
Listen, I'm trying, okay?
But it's kind of a rough situation.
Where's the energy?
I don't know what you mean by rough situation.
I don't feel a passion, Bogr.
Where's your passion?
I feel like you're giving up.
Your time zone is not my problem.
You know how long it's gonna be.
We can try triple support.
We can do anything.
You knew the schedule, Bogr.
You could have slept earlier.
I did actually take a nap.
But it is hard for me to triple support if there's no Luna and no Cloak.
I'm sorry to say this, I don't think we protect Penny.
I think we need to protect the support ult.
And we need support ults.
They know they can just overpower with APS ults.
If we do that, we can just run triple support then.
Cloak or Luna?
Cloak is better.
Or we can play Luna as well.
We banned Cloak.
Didn't they ban Cloak first?
Luna ult is kind of better.
No, Cloak ult is better.
Sorry, I mean easier.
Depending on what they're playing, how easy it is to react to a certain ult.
But I could do either.
I think they're going to ban Cloak again.
I guess we can protect whichever one they don't.
They're going to ban one support.
So we just need to protect the other one.
Honestly, we did pretty well.
Considering...
Considering the fact that I wasn't so energetic.
And I've given up, obviously.
You gave up?
He gave up because Karrick yelled at him.
And then his soul...
Guys, shut the fuck up.
I'm crashing out.
He yelled at him in front of everybody.
So now he's crashing out.
I'm crashing out.
Wait, are they picking map?
I think so, but I don't think they care.
I'm just playing to play.
I'm a support champ.
I wanted DPS.
Fulgur doesn't want to die.
Okay.
I won a game.
Okay, it was against Karrick's team.
Yesterday, last night.
I literally won a game with 4 DPS and 2 supports.
It was actually crazy.
Because Karrick's team was like...
2-2-2.
Like a normal fucking team comp.
And then...
Our tank player...
Crashed out and played DPS.
And was yelling at our other DPS.
And was like, what the fuck are you guys doing?
And then our tank player...
Ended up getting like...
30 plus kills after this.
Watch the TV.
I'm banning Storm Dance.
No, we can ban Garou.
No, let's ban Storm.
They ended up like...
Ended up out-damaging...
And out-killing our other 3 DPS.
Wait, it wasn't even our tank player.
It was our support player.
No, our support player crashed out.
Our support player swapped to DPS.
And then our tank player...
Had to swap to support.
So we had...
4 DPS and whatnot.
It wasn't even our tank that crashed out.
It was my other support.
And then they ended up getting 3 plus kills.
And MVP ace.
And they were like...
Can anyone please swap with me, please?
You guys are doing nothing.
That's so crazy.
But yeah, I won against it.
And then I was re-watching Krooky's VOD yesterday.
And like...
2 people on his team was crashing out.
They lost against my team.
I know.
I don't think so.
I'll be honest.
Wait,
they didn't protect a second.
I guess they didn't care.
I'll be honest with you, bro.
I'll be honest with you.
No, they pity us!
No!
No, they think we're such a big threat.
I think they're not gonna ban even.
Oh, they did ban Wolverine.
Alright.
Alright, Wolverine.
I know what you guys are missing from the comp.
No, probably not.
I'll just compliment whoever plays the other support.
Alright.
Honestly, I love that.
I can Luna.
I can Penny.
What's the vibe?
The vibes are triple support, I think.
Maybe.
Period.
Don't go, Adam.
Wait, are you serious?
Adam is last season meta.
He's not this season meta.
That's why.
We need support loads.
Is that a Sue or Loki?
You gotta go Sue or Loki.
It's fine, it's fine.
Doki is gonna play support.
Lulu, do you play support or do you wanna play this?
I can do either.
It's just what you think would be better for the team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go support.
Doki, go support.
And you...
You...
Know what you're thinking.
Do it, do it, do it.
We gotta pick Sue, guys.
I'm not joking.
You don't wanna play Strange?
The thing is, they have so much damage.
My shield just breaks.
I need something to do with her Punisher.
I feel like you doing damage as well is helpful.
The thing is, I'm solo tanking and second of all, they have so much damage.
MrFantastic is basically another tank.
He's like a sub-tank.
I'm gonna have to swap off Loki, they have a Moon Knight.
Choose Strange, choose Strange.
There's a...
There's an Immortar left.
Can we kill him?
Yeah, he was just free farming.
He's floating up above us.
Half health.
I'm trying, I'm really trying.
But the tentacles are killing me.
I'm going to swap.
Yeah, we need to deal with the Immortar on the flank.
I'm not gonna lie...
Yeah, we really do need to focus him.
He was pretty much in our faces.
Maybe MrFantastic here can deal with him.
Wait, I was on him the whole time.
You were not on him, I died.
No, you weren't.
Come right side.
Let's go right side.
I'm just poking them here.
Just play behind the angles.
Behind the walls.
I'm shooting the Moira.
Yeah, we're chilling.
The octopus.
Yeah, I'm shooting the octopus.
The Moira has nothing.
Honestly, you can swap, MrFantastic, if you don't feel it.
I'm pushing X.
Nice kill, nice kill.
X half, X half.
Just do anything, it's fine.
I have my ult.
Switch off.
I'm pressing.
Nice.
I'm doing as much as I can.
We still have our MrFantastic here.
Look at Namor.
Namor, Namor, Namor.
Okay.
I'm 1 HP.
I'm so low to start.
Maybe I can go strangers.
We have Luna.
Come back, come back.
I can TP, I can TP.
I'm alright here.
I'm alive.
Hey guys.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm going Prime.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Ulting.
Change as ult, by the way.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
Yeah, deal with it, guys.
I need to kill the backline.
He's gonna have ult, so he's waiting for it.
I have push, I think.
Oh yeah, he's not.
They flipped him up, guys.
They're behind us.
Guys, the tentacles!
On point, and he's half HP.
I don't know if anymore, but...
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Strange half, strange half.
Nice.
I'm on strange, I'm on strange.
Strange half, strange half.
I pulled him, I pulled him back to us.
That's sick.
Nice.
I got him, I got him.
I need heals, I need heals.
Behind, behind, behind!
We can kill him more, we can kill him more!
I pulled him to us, kill him, kill him!
Nice, nice.
Good pull, good pull, good pull.
Yeah, you're good, you're good.
Honestly, pretty good, pretty good.
Let's farm support ults.
I have ult in...
We'll mantis ult first, we'll mantis ult first.
Can you try to boop him when he flies in?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we'll try, we'll try.
That's good, we'll save it.
And you can slow with your pentakill.
We mantis ult first, remember?
I'm waiting for them to come in before I ult you.
Yeah, just don't, yeah, stay on the left side.
I'm on him, I'm on him.
I'm chilling.
Chase is looking for an ult.
No more left side?
I'm cheating.
Yeah, I'm looking at it too.
Guys, I'm going to hit a phat ult here.
Oh, he's going to kill himself!
I see you, I see you, I see you.
Chase pushing in.
I don't have push, I don't have push.
No reason.
I ulted, I ulted, I ulted.
I might die though, I can die from this.
I pushed, I couldn't push him anywhere.
He was against the wall.
We have mantis ult here if you can.
I'm coming over.
Nice, I'm coming over now.
Kill the stranger.
Kill the stranger, I'm blocking off heals.
Oh my god, guys!
Go see him!
Oh my god, sorry, I celebrated too late.
Let's go, guys!
Guys, this is my first win.
Like, round win.
Good job, guys.
I take that as a win at that point.
I'm taking that as a win.
It's been a rough month for me.
Okay, how do we feel about Jeff?
Yeah, I can swap to Jeff if you'd like.
Do you want me to?
But I also feel like Luna must be so much better.
No, Luna is a lot better.
Listen, I've had a lot of Jeffs in my ranked games.
Does anyone play Jeff?
I don't think we play Jeff, I agree with you.
Wait, I actually play Jeff.
I play the four most useless characters in the game.
I'm not even kidding.
Do you guys want me to swap off Luna to Jeff?
No, no, no.
That's what I figured.
I would swap Mantis for Jeff.
Oh, I see.
This is not a Jeff match.
Oh my god!
I'm on the ground with Scarra!
I might be dead, though.
Yeah, I think we lose this.
That's too many things.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
You guys got fucking deleted.
Wait, am I on the wrong side?
You're on the wrong side.
He's dead, we have to wait for you.
Flipped, we flipped.
It's fine, we don't have any...
We need to play slow here, get some moves.
Yeah, I almost have mine.
On my way.
This is a bad time to tell you guys.
This is my fourth time playing Invisible Woman.
You're gonna learn.
I'm learning as we go.
Oh, their chunk is held.
Kill the thing.
I got hit by that, I couldn't heal him.
It's fine.
He's still alive.
I have ult, so I don't know if you guys want me to use mine.
I think Moon Knight has ult.
Thought you wouldn't see me again.
I need heals down low.
You're up one.
Just play on point.
Just play on point with Bulgar.
Just play on point with him.
I'm gonna ult us.
Nice!
Get in there more if you can.
Can we kill the...
Sorry, I'm so sorry.
I smashed you all.
Thank you.
I couldn't grab him.
Oh no.
Got you.
I need heals real quick.
Can you look at me?
I'm on strain.
Okay, I got you.
I can mash guys.
I'm ulting.
I'm on Moon Knight.
Their tentacles, guys.
I'm on them more.
Yeah, look into more.
Two swarm.
Nice, nice.
We don't need ults.
Wait, wait, wait.
Tragedy is on me.
I'm pushing them away.
Push them.
Tragedy on me again.
Looking at strange.
I can heal you, don't worry.
Get strange if you can.
I got you.
Mantis.
Change one.
Stroke is strange.
He's so low.
He's literally by himself, jaywalking.
Next to me.
He's fucking...
We have sualt if we need it.
Yeah, I saved my sualt for this.
I got my ult as well here, guys.
I need heals.
I have my ult.
If they push on point...
I'm using my ult.
Come to me.
We win this.
He heals.
Use ult.
I killed everyone.
It's winnable.
It's fine.
Focus on the more.
The more high ground.
Oh my god.
We did it!
We played so well.
Oh my god.
We did it, guys.
I did this.
Good job.
I just strange diffed him so hard.
Yes, and also, I think Boger just needed to be happy.
He needed the positive vibes.
Yes.
The curse is broken.
I'm not crying.
Oh, for sure.
We just made it.
We just wanted to make the game more fair, right?
Oh, right.
Oh my god.
No more depression.
I know.
It's that easy.
I'm happy for the rest of my day.
We just started.
I'm happy now.
I was on the biggest lose streak.
Let's go!
We broke it.
We did it.
We did it, Nora.
I thought it was going to go 0-10 for the rest of the day.
Is there a reward for going 0-10?
That's crazy.
I'll take that 1-9.
I'll take it.
That was crazy, guys.
You played well.
You popped off, guys.
It's just that easy to cure depression.
You made a crazy Udyr.
I strangled 4 of them at the end.
I killed everyone.
Yeah, you should have just played estranged the entire time.
I like how xQc was triple support, crutch.
We needed this, though.
We needed the crutch.
We needed the crutch, yeah.
Jesus Christ.
He has Trowd.
Come on, you have Trowd.
Yep, we're playing against each other in 3 days.
Let's recap tomorrow.
GG's, guys.
GG's, good luck.
Good luck, everybody.
Oh my god.
I like how we're the only team that just left.
We didn't have to leave.
Everybody else was still in their fucking lobby.
Guys, I keep forgetting that you shift on invisible.
That was literally the 4th time I've ever played.
Okay, let me see.
Actually, I'm curious.
How many times have I played invisible woman?
I'm actually curious.
I played her like once in ranked game.
I think I've only played her once in ranked.
I'm pretty sure.
Statistics.
There we go.
My 4th game on invisible woman.
That's literally it.
I told you guys.
This is actually my 4th game on her.
It's not muscle memory for me.
The shift.
Not even a full game.
Oh my god.
This is not fantastic.
Zero rocket hours and we're keeping it that way.
Two minutes?
Yeah, two minutes.
I wouldn't use Jeff to stall.
To swim back to the...
To swim to the place.
If it's last overtime.
And we need to support.
We need to support over fast.
I just swim over as fast as I can.
I have a better win rate on Cloak than I do on Luna.
It's so sad.
And also, yeah.
I'm competitive.
Yeah, I have a better win rate on...
No, I will never.
Look at that.
No, my Atom is where it's at.
100% win rate.
Right here.
But yeah, that's actually my 4th game on...
Like I said.
I feel like even if...
Even if Invisible Woman is not my strongest support.
I'd rather put our lower ranked players...
On their best support character.
Instead of like...
Putting them on something they're not comfortable with.
Because like...
My...
I feel like my...
My Invisible Woman...
Because they're my...
Not my worst one.
Because like, I don't know.
I feel like my other support might be worse.
I feel like...
My game sense...
In a higher ELO...
Can easily transfer...
To other supports.
So I can just transfer it better.
Like knowledge wise.
And stuff.
Yeah, I can make use of...
Like my pulls.
I felt like my pulls...
And my pushes...
Clutched some of the matches there.
Where I like pulled...
I like pulled and pushed...
Some of the players...
Like some of the enemy members towards us.
And we got picks because of it.
And I felt like I could...
Like I was able to do that.
I feel like me being on Invisible Woman...
Helped us.
I'm happy for the rest of the day.
I actually went in thinking like...
Oh man, I'm gonna get 0-10.
Yeah, yeah.
I was just like...
I literally went in thinking I was gonna get 0-10.
So I'm happy, you know.
I'm actually...
I'm happy for the rest of the day.
I'm undooming, that's how it works.
Like...
I don't know, they're like...
Doki, why are you dooming?
And I'm like, I don't know.
I feel like this...
You can't...
With this record...
It's a little hard to be positive.
Guys, guys, guys.
Guys, this looks a lot better though.
As long as we don't...
As long as we don't look at this part.
Much better.
We kept the streak.
xQc has yet to win a game against me.
He hasn't won a game with me too.
But like, that's...
That still counts, guys.
That technically still counts.
Kept the streak going.
Thank god.
Actually, thank god.
I don't know why we all just left.
Why did we all like...
We were the only ones that left our lobby.
I just realized.
Doki, come back.
What?
Doki, you won the game with me.
I also lost a game with you.
I have never...
Listen, I have never diffed somebody as hard as I diffed Dexter.
That was insane.
Yeah, but we're playing against you.
We're playing against you again.
Get out of here.
I'm playing against you next game.
Come to the lobby.
Where are you?
I'm here now.
I'm pretty sure the other team hasn't finished their game yet.
Yeah, we're chilling.
We're just chatting.
Did you think we were going to win that game?
No.
I was actually so locked in.
You know those moments when you play competitive games?
I was in the flow.
You literally got through the 4k that last round.
He couldn't hit a single fucking ult.
That's crazy.
No, he held his ult.
I was saving my push.
My pressure was greater.
I literally waited for so long to push him.
But he held his ult for the longest time.
I was so confused.
I was looking at my stats in my chat and that was literally the 4th time I've ever played Invisible.
What?
You're the best.
I was just like, hey guys.
My first win on Invisible Women.
I think we were the first team that finished too.
Everybody's still playing.
You know your team?
You know your team for the next round?
Actually, we're pretty stacked I think.
Our team is pretty stacked too.
What are you talking about?
You don't have tank players.
Oh shit.
No, we have Coney's tank player.
Coney's tank player.
I'm not telling you.
I'm not fucking telling you.
Oh, apparently SK's match went to overtime.
That's what we're waiting on.
Oh man.
Coney is our only tank.
The only issue is that we have to ban Strange.
I'm just going to tell my team to ban Strange.
Because I think Bogr on Strange is literally the carry.
I think if he was on Hulk, I'll just...
Unless Bogr bans Luna, I can just freeze Hulk on cooldown.
Because that's what I did to him and he wasn't having a good time.
So that's really it.
As long as he doesn't ban Luna, then we should be fine.
I can just freeze him on cooldown if he's on Hulk.
Or we just ban Hulk second.
Because honestly, nobody else is someone I'm like, oh man, I gotta worry about that.
In terms of ban-wise.
They have all the DPS players though.
Their team is literally just DPS players.
Bogr's team.
Bogr's team is literally...
It's like Masayoshi, Qtpie, Nora, Tariq, and Shoto.
They're all DPS players.
And my team actually has...
I mean, Coney and Scarra can both play tank.
And me and Sleepy can play DPS if he feels like it today.
I just play low-key because that's basically DPS.
But...
Yeah.
I feel a lot better.
I feel like...
I feel...
Legitimately, I was like, oh man.
But now I'm like, Yay!
Maybe things aren't that bad in life.
My depression is cured.
It only takes one thing.
No longer demoralized.
I mean, when your teammates were dying on cooldown and I was practically like, you know, I had to like...
I was just, you know...
I was literally just fucking begging for heals.
Doki, can you invite me into the lobby again?
Because I...
It was pretty rough.
Yeah, I can.
Wait, but you're not leader anymore.
Oh wait, I'm leader.
I'll just invite you back in.
And then I'll give you leader.
Wait.
Wait, I can give you leader.
I don't think you can.
I think you have to create it yourself.
Yeah, doesn't matter.
It won't let you give leader.
Wait, that's so dumb.
What?
That's actually so dumb.
But yeah, someone said leave and RNG it, but like, that's not worth.
I feel like RNG is not going to go to you.
Hmm.
I'm going to leave and see if it goes to you.
Did you get it?
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Alright, invite me back in.
Where the fuck is my room, booger?
How do we make the other person team leader then?
Or the other team?
I don't know.
Do I just have to not be at the... Oh, I need to invite you.
Why does this person keep leaving the lobby?
I'm so confused.
What?
I'm confused.
Are you in the room, Doki?
Yeah, I'm literally in your room right now.
Okay.
Who is missing?
Like, the rest of the other team.
Like...
Sleepy's team.
They're still in a game right now.
They are?
Yeah, because SK's team went overtime.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
Void has also lost at almost all his games.
Just like me.
Just like me as well.
Oh my god.
We both won one.
Oh no.
I just...
Masayoshi has won four out of his five games.
Must be...
Must feel great.
That's crazy.
Yeah, and he's on your team.
Must feel great.
Wait, Tariq has won...
Wait.
No, what?
Half...
Who's Halfu's replacement?
Is it QT?
What do you mean replacement?
Halfu's playing now.
Is Halfu playing?
I played with Halfu.
First game we played.
I thought Halfu got replaced by...
Wait, nevermind.
I thought Halfu was the one that got replaced earlier.
It was someone else.
It was Myth that got replaced.
Guys, I'm looking at the scores right now.
I'm not going to link it to you guys.
Because, you know...
Because I still want some joy in my life.
But some people don't have the link.
Some people don't have the link.
And I prefer to keep it that way.
I have one point.
Guys, come on.
We're not progressing to the finals.
But at least I have one point.
And that's all that matters.
It must be nice to...
It must be nice to not be a support player.
It must be nice.
Maybe I'll get Eternity.
To make it feel better.
That one singular point.
I beat xQc and Shroud.
Who's winning here?
Some of them only fought xQc.
Some of them only fought Shroud.
But I fought both xQc and Shroud.
And won.
And I guess Tariq too.
I'm sorry, but Tariq is a great guy.
He's just randomly catching strays right now.
Those three were all on the same team together.
And I still made it.
I still made it out.
That's a good start.
Round 3?
How are they on round 3?
It's best of 2!
It's two maps!
You play two games!
Oh they didn't get past their other.
Yeah.
That one point was worth the entire day.
Yeah, I just need to make sure I don't play Invisible Woman again.
That's not true, we lost like the other round.
It's like a 50% invisible win rate.
Because we lost that other game on Invisible Woman.
You know, the first round, we lost that.
So like, that's not true guys.
We've already tainted it.
I'm just happy.
I'm happy we made it out.
That's true.
That game was a warm-up to figure out how to play her.
That is so true.
I had to figure out her mechanics there.
I would love to play the finals.
I think if I got a chance to play the finals, it would have been so fun.
In general.
But like, it is what it is.
There can only be two teams that make it out.
It is what it is.
I mean, it's nice just to talk to people I usually never talk to before.
I still can't believe my Discord.
I'm sorry that you guys don't know who's talking and stuff.
And all the cool big name people that were with us and stuff.
Wait, let me see.
If I refresh this, does it fix it?
Maybe?
No, it still breaks it.
I don't know why my Discord is broken.
Like, I don't know why.
I feel like if I restarted my PC, maybe it would work.
But, oh my god.
I'm so mad.
Now it works.
But not the way I want it to.
I'm so mad.
I'm so angry.
I'm so, oh my god, I'm so mad.
Alright,
let me see if I can do it.
Okay, let's see.
I'm here.
Hello.
Hello again, booger.
Oh, it doesn't work.
This is the...
Who's our team?
Let me see.
Not me.
I'm just crashing.
Because I think my lobby people are...
Yeah, we just finished up.
Wait, wait.
Cody, I also play Mr. Fantastic.
No, Scarra, I'm sorry.
Scarra, you're on tank duty.
Oh!
You're on tank duty.
I do not have two players that go, I like Mr. Fantastic.
That's great.
What can I say?
He's fun, bro.
He's fun.
Sleepy, let me tell you my character pool.
I play...
I was actually asking about this.
Let's hear it.
I play Penny, Mr. Fantastic, Adam Warlock.
Okay, so not a single useful character.
Alright.
What?
What's your favorite character?
Who do you think you're going to play the best on?
Because that's not everyone they're comfortable on, honestly.
I don't want to make anybody like Scarra.
Alright, who do I need to invite?
Me.
Scarra, who do you like?
The other problem is, do we have a tank player?
Cody plays tank.
Hi, Doki!
Yeah, Cody, I'm calling you out.
You're not playing Mr. Fantastic.
You're on tank duty.
No, I'm playing Mr. Fantastic.
I'm 5-1!
I'm 5-1 tonight!
Oh, he's 5-1?
Yes, I'm 5-1!
I don't lose!
I, as the Discord admin of this channel, allow him to play...
Yes!
Don't you quote me!
If you have a problem with it, you're going to get banned from my Discord.
Who still needs invite?
Me, me, me, me.
Thank you!
Yeah, ban me!
Do it, then!
Invite...
He plays two Codys, Cody.
Do it!
Play 5v6!
Who?
Where are you, Scarra?
Can you request?
What's your name again?
Oh, hold on, I see it.
I requested.
Alright, nice.
Shit, I'll just play Mag, it's fine.
Is that your number one?
Like, you're happy on that?
Um...
Like, don't worry about what anybody else is playing.
What do you want to play, number one?
Mr. Fantastic.
I can actually play Mag.
I can play Mag.
Honestly, you might be Mag, because the scenario I had in my brain, which led to ggwellplayed, is me on Mag.
And I don't really like that, so...
No, no, I'm playing Mag, it's fine.
Are you sure?
Scarra, I'm down to swap, brother.
If you want to.
No, no, no.
I think you're him on Mr. Fantastic.
I'll just watch.
I sure am.
You're right about that.
I'll watch and take notes.
Yeah, I'll send you the replay later.
Okay, we have the best team.
Boger was, like, single handedly killing games on Strange.
When you have two Mr. Fantastic enjoyers on one team, that's crazy.
Two fantastic names, okay.
Boger was...
Wait, Boger was...
I played on Boger's team that game.
He was Hulk.
No, no, no.
Last game.
I was on his team last game.
But he literally, like, dipped xQc so hard on Strange.
He should have been on...
I think it's a little fucked because he just plays everything.
No, no, no.
His Hulk is not as good as a Strange, trust me.
Really?
I watched it.
He is literally a Strange one trick.
Not one trick, but, like, he's a Strange main.
I also do know Boger as, like, a Strange main.
Strange needs to be banned, like, because...
Yeah, I'm down to ban him.
So, like, the difference between, like, his Strange and whatever I play is gonna be really bad.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
He, like, dipped xQc hard on Strange.
So, like, I'd rather just not deal with his Strange.
Yeah, if he's a Strange main, we know that his computer doesn't crash from Dr. Strange portals.
So, who's playing what?
I can flex whatever for support.
I also support main Unforged.
If you play against Necros, just save and pick Strange.
Oh, we have Sleepy as well.
Can I have an invite, please?
The lobby's full, but...
Someone has to be kicked, then, right?
Wait, what?
Who has to be kicked?
This Imaqtpie guy, is he playing?
Yeah.
Oh, he is.
Someone on our team has to be kicked.
Wait a second, let me think.
Oh, Selene, right?
Selene.
Uh-oh.
Who's Hampoon?
That's me.
Oh.
Hello.
I'll just watch.
Oh my god, you got to Diamond, Coney?
You finally did it.
His name is Fake Doki, you know that.
I'm so proud of you.
Oh, Doki, you're Celestial?
Yeah.
I didn't play for two weeks, though, so...
I came back yesterday and went from Celestial 3 to Celestial 1.
Oh yeah, so you got a tummy ache.
So you're a god, right?
No.
I'm just a support player.
Did you get food poisoning?
Yeah, I got food poisoning in Japan.
I don't know how.
I literally was like the only person that got it.
I filled for us.
We won last game, but it was a pretty bad Punisher.
I played Punisher for us.
You did crazy.
You did great.
You went all in.
Yeah, you did your job.
I don't think I did great, but thank you.
But who won?
You did great, Hampoon.
Did you win?
We did win, we did win.
You won.
If push comes to shove, I can feel Punisher and Hella.
I can also flex the DPS.
My best DPS is Psylocke.
Oh, Doki, I wanted to thank you in person.
Oh yeah, congrats, SeanBamil.
We're almost at 1 mil.
I made you.
Thanks for the follow me.
That is crazy.
Yeah, he made a video on the Twitch Rivals shit, and then it got almost a million views in six days.
My normal YouTube numbers are like 50,000, and this shit makes no sense.
Because this one's at a million, and nothing else is even close.
What do you mean?
It makes perfect sense.
Doki's face is on it.
You can use me as clickbait, and you can farm the drama.
Farm as much as you want.
On your next video without Doki, just put her face in it.
I'm going to make a video about this tournament and still find a way to flame xQc.
I'll make another video about this.
That'll be fun.
Wait, have you beat xQc yet?
We play next round, actually.
That's the one time we play.
Wait,
I'm banning?
Oh shit, okay.
I'm banning.
Okay, what are we protecting?
Loki.
Oh, they banned your Loki.
What are we protecting?
Honestly, because what else do we need to protect?
Oh, you want to protect Mr. Fantastic?
I'll save Luna.
You guys don't want to save Fantastic?
Bro, he's right here, man.
If I draw a ban at any point in this tournament, I won the tournament.
That's all I care about.
Okay, so who are we banning next?
That's his next video then.
They were scared of my Mr. Fantastic.
Let me look at the characters.
Maybe Hulk?
I'm down for Hulk.
Okay, ban Hulk.
I'll ban Hulk.
Wait, he said Groot.
What does Taric play if not Groot?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Should we not ban...
Groot's not even that scary.
Should we not ban Rocket?
They saved Punisher.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, let's just ban Rocket.
They just don't have...
I'll just ban Rocket.
That's right.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Alright, I'll play whatever.
He's gonna play... I'll freeze.
I'll just try and freeze the Hulk as much as I can.
Alright.
I hate support players.
I hate you too.
Wait, Connie, what skin are you using?
The one skin he has, bro.
You know I gotta go Maker.
Oh, shit.
I've never seen the MVP screen for that skin I bought.
You probably won't today.
I don't know if you can see it, but we'll give it a shot.
Wait, so we're triple DPSing this?
Yeah, that's fine.
I mean, if it doesn't work, we're just one trip support.
Yeah, is Connie really a DPS?
Not really, no.
I'll put the...
Oh, wait, we have Starlord.
Okay, I'll put the orb on the Starlord then.
Thank you.
Who the fuck is whistling?
Hey, stop whistling.
Stop whistling!
I like the whistling.
It's good for morale.
They have Moon Knight Groot.
They just can do that over and over.
Oh, they do.
Yeah, that's why I was down to ban the Groot.
Oh, you guys have their walls.
Oh, got walled and anked here.
I was fine with the wall, but the anked there messed me up.
I might need...
Thank you.
I'm going to try to get a kill.
No.
Oh my god.
He died when I was expecting it.
I'm sorry, what do I do?
We ban Strange.
Wait, I might be dead.
I might be stacked.
I was like, wait, we ban him.
I think you have to play with us because we're getting built by Thor.
Yeah, I missed my freeze.
I can play back too.
I wasn't expecting it.
Can we touch this?
I don't think we can.
No way.
We can touch this.
I put a thing there.
I got you, I got you.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking up my freezes.
Holy shit, man.
I'm just getting deleted immediately.
Can somebody in the LA area go to Jon's house and punch him in the fucking head?
I have my ult.
We should maybe close the ult in.
Yeah, I can.
Since they already used Brutal.
They haven't used Moon Knight ult, by the way.
Nice, nice.
I'm going to die to this.
He's one, he's one.
I didn't want him to force ult off me.
Behind you, Wes.
He's one.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Can we get back?
Oh, are we down?
No, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm just trying to get some time here.
Here.
Okay.
Got it.
Three, two, one.
I might be dead after my ult.
I'm okay, I am.
Moon Knight here.
I froze him, I froze him.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
They have Brutal here, they have Brutal.
Nice, nice, push up, push up.
I got all supports down.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I got...
No supports, no supports.
Yeah, we're good.
They have Moon Knight ult here.
I'm coming back now.
Die, you fat fuck.
There we go.
They have Moon Knight, they just grew at the end.
Nah, they're close.
I need to put the orb on...
I'll make that more immuno, honestly.
I think I was worried.
I'm just trying to trust my backline.
I can't get to you, Kurt, I can't.
Can you heal me?
Yeah, yeah, I'm good.
Nice.
There's a Groot to our left, Groot to our left.
Groot by himself.
Nice, nice, nice.
Groot is still here.
He's trying to farm ult, he's farming ult.
He's dead, he's dead.
I have my ult, I have my ult.
He's gonna have Groot ult again soon.
Okay.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
Good hold.
You're good, you're good.
They're gonna have Moon Knight ult already.
Just watch Groot, Moon Knight ult.
They're gonna have Thor as well.
No, they used Thor, they used Thor.
They tried to solo ult, they're close.
He's up here.
I'm trying to get him.
I got you, I got you.
I'm going, I'm going.
Shit, I'm on a wall.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Yeah, yeah, I'm waiting, I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
We don't have to match yet.
I'm on Namor, he's one.
Okay, okay.
He's gonna ult us, he wants to ult us, he wants to ult us.
I know, I know, I know.
They pushed up, they pushed up a bit.
Careful for Groot, careful for Groot.
Don't take stack, don't take stack.
Oh, yeah, I can't.
You guys are not living that.
I'm dead here.
Oh, they got their ult combo.
That was gonna happen.
Wait,
do we have... yeah, we could...
We'll... there's Groot.
I'm over here now.
Thor, Thor.
You're behind, you're behind, you're walled off.
Yeah, yeah.
We gotta group up.
Yeah.
I got you, I got you.
I froze him, I froze him.
I have my ult in a sec, 90.
Yeah, yeah, I can try it.
I'm going.
I need to reload.
I'm walled.
I have like a squid on me and I can't heal.
Yeah, I'm coming to you.
Thank you.
They're gonna have Groot ult combo again.
They have Groot.
Nice, nice, got it.
Alright, they got a minute.
We can ult.
They're gonna combo.
They have combo, they have combo.
Hold up because I wanna get the combo out early if we can.
Stay split, stay split with the backline.
And then yeah, can you just look at Thor?
You can just double trap him.
Yeah.
Kill him, kill him, kill him.
Oh, you pulled him away from me.
You're walled out, Camille.
They're looking for it, they're looking for it.
Stay split, stay split.
I froze Thor, I froze Thor to my right, left.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
I'm on me.
It's fine, I've saved the front.
Moonlight's low.
3, 2, 1, I'm backing out, I'm backing out, I'm backing out.
I froze Groot, I froze Groot.
I'm trying to steal.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Thor left, Thor left.
Low, low, low, low, low.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I'm ulting Thor, I'm ulting Thor, I'm ulting Thor.
Thor, Thor, Thor.
Yes, Thor down.
I'm piting it.
Reloading.
You're walled out, walled out, I got you, I got you.
I got it, I got it, I'm back.
Fuck me.
I see you, I see you, I see you.
I got you, I got you.
Push up, push up, push up, push up.
Oh, I might be dead.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor is on me.
I'm on him, I'm on him, I'm on him.
I got somebody before I died.
No, no, no, behind Thor.
I have all innate.
I'm just going.
It's Thor.
I'm coming back.
I'm on my way back, I'm on my way back.
Oh shit.
Tris, tris, tris, tris, tris, tris, tris, tris.
Honestly, fine hold.
I mean, we went 99, 99.
Yeah.
Winnable.
If they're on Thor again, yeah, just keep putting our skruggle on them, I think.
Just CC them down if you can.
You'll need a top notch team to win this one.
I can still hold the team.
That was just, that was unfortunate, Kone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I could've touched.
I didn't notice that she wasn't right.
Before that, you saved John.
I was trying to pull him into our team.
I didn't realize.
I had him double nutted and I'm like point blank just shotgunning him with my fucking nuts.
And Kone pulls him out of the corridor.
I tried to pull him into the team, I thought we had him.
No, that was just, that was unlucky, that was unlucky.
That's tough.
We got this though.
Because we got, we held them all the way to the end.
They got zero seconds.
Yeah, yeah, we got this, we got this.
Just do it again.
I don't know if I should do the Namor team up or if I should do Storm.
Wait, I could say Storm goes hard.
What does?
Storm?
I think Storm would go hard.
Really?
I feel like Namor is doing a lot.
Yeah, I think they're both good.
We're pushing though, right?
Yeah.
Whatever you want, you know better than me.
You know better than me.
I feel like I have to put my orb on Mag just because...
Yeah, the walls.
Oh my gosh.
I froze somebody, I don't know who.
I can heal you, yeah.
Oh!
I'm walking up, I'm walking up.
Careful on the right.
I'm reloading.
Reloading here.
I froze him.
Yeah, I'm swapping to Starlord.
I'm healing.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
You're just walling the supports.
Walls are not okay.
Yeah, we need someone to shoot the walls too.
I don't know, I can't really play the game.
I'm gonna do the Storm.
I can't play the game.
Lunite down, Lunite down.
I literally have all of their fucking supports on me.
Thor has ult, Thor has ult.
And so does Groot.
I missed mine, I need to use this.
I'm using it.
We just use this to push up.
No more bubble down.
I'm using the push up.
I'm backing up.
Get to the wall, get to the wall, get to the wall.
I froze the Groot, I froze the Groot.
He has ult, he has ult.
He's looking for it.
He still ulted me, he still ulted me.
I still have the tank on me.
I don't know if I can kill this.
He's half, he's low.
Can we kill Thor?
He's half, he's half, he's solo, he's solo.
Just one hit, one hit.
I got him.
I got you.
Walking up, walking up.
I'm walking in, I'm walking in, I'm walking in.
I'm on the cart, I'm on the cart.
No more, no more, no more.
Can I get a heal?
Got you.
On us.
What the hell is this?
Walk up B, walk up B.
Okay, I'm playing aggro.
I'm gonna walk up a little.
You can, you can, you can.
Yeah, I'm walking up, I'm walking up.
I should stay, right?
Am I supposed to go up?
No, no, no, no, stay on cart for now.
I just want my ult first because mine's closest.
Yeah.
They subbed Groot ult.
They're gonna have Groot ult here.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Pulling back.
Go with it first, go with it first.
Push, push, push, push.
Yeah, help him if you can, help him if you can.
We don't need to use anything, we don't need to use anything.
We win this, we win this.
Good job, good job.
We're pushing cart, supports are pushing cart.
We need one more, we need one more.
Yeah, you're by yourself by the way.
I don't have an orb.
He is free.
Fuck you, John!
You want me to ult?
Should I ult?
Mag, mag.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Thank you.
I'm on mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
Nice, nice, nice, mag, mag, mag.
Focus mag, focus mag.
He's one, he's one.
I got him.
We have four minutes.
I'm pushing.
You can push up, I have ult, I have ult.
We can win this fight with just my ults, okay?
Nothing else.
I'm gonna go in, you guys need to push.
Yeah, I'm not close yet.
Let's stall the fight out as long as we can.
Until they make a fight.
I'm pulling mag.
Guys, no shield.
Give me shield.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I bubbled us.
Oh no, I thought I could get to you.
I'm just gonna force the fight here.
No, you didn't.
We got mag ult out though.
That's fine, we got mag ult.
I think it's a good trade.
If she jumps, it breaks.
Any action.
I poked on the impact.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I have ult still.
Start the fight, use your ult mid fight, Abe.
I have 885.
I'm 888 on my ult.
I'm with you, Cody, I'm with you.
Do you support ulti?
I'm ulting, yeah.
Oh, sorry, no?
No, no, no, there was support behind us.
Hello ulti, hello ulti.
I have athor on me.
He got bubbled.
Maybe just wait.
There's a thor in spawn, I think.
Do that, do that, do that.
I need heal.
That's all their support ults.
Let's try to play aggro here.
At the end of support ults.
Playing up.
Pulling Thor.
I missed my froze.
Hitting Hela, Hela low.
They're all low, they're all so low.
Nice, nice, nice.
Mag, Mag, focus Mag, focus Mag.
Kill Hela, kill Hela.
Oh, nice, nice.
I got you, I got you, Cody.
We're even, we're even, we're even.
Mag, Mag, one Mag, one.
Got her.
Nice.
I'm solo, I'm solo, I can't.
I froze Thor, but like, he's behind us.
I'm pushing him away, I'm pushing him away.
That's two, that's two dead.
I'm gonna die.
I'm back up.
Yeah, Thor is delaying a cart push.
Cart push, please.
This is last fight, this is last fight.
I'm killing, I'm killing, I'm killing.
All right, heal.
I'm out, I'm gonna...
We can use, we can use, we can use.
I need to get...
Thor, Thor.
Thor is one, Thor is one.
Thor, I'm on Thor.
Nice, nice, nice.
They swirled through?
Yeah, they did.
They reload.
They're gonna have ult soon.
I got you, I got you.
They reloaded, they reloaded.
My bubble is up.
Oh, I'm 91.
Ah, I hit nothing, I hit nothing.
Ah, nice try.
Shit.
Really close, really close.
I think we can either ban Groot or Thor.
Yeah.
Sure.
That was close, damn.
That was a close game, yeah.
Thor is a problem.
That was, that was a problem.
We definitely need support, needs more peel against the Thor.
Yeah, I can play backline a little bit more.
Cause I'm, I'm missing my freeze.
His movement is weird.
I'm like, I feel like he's moving in a way I'm not predicting.
Or my freezes.
I mean, he's like, able to dps my heals on you, too.
Like, even when I bubble, I feel like you die.
Yeah, like the only way to avoid it is just I need, we need like someone to look back at us to help us, or like, even with freezes, like, it's difficult.
Oh.
Hey, Captain.
Oh, this guy's literally muted.
He hates us.
Sleepy, what map?
Um, I just go Koth, always Koth.
I think we have to protect Luna, though, cause Luna's the only way to actually have, like, some CC control against her.
I don't like that.
Sleepy, you know the map that we played, the first map we played last game?
The Bucky one?
I don't remember which one, but...
Uh, was it Koth?
Yeah, it was Koth.
Oh, it was the Bast one.
Yeah, I did not like that one.
Anything but the Bast one, because Abraham is a distinguished and handsome fellow.
Oh, Sleepy, you know what's funny about that game, too?
What?
We, uh, picked the wrong map for that.
Oh, yeah.
That was difficult.
I've been missing my...
I was missing my punishments, too.
It was my fault.
We were trying to play the other one.
It's like the same map, but not Koth.
I can't up Sleepy even more.
He's literally at 200%.
I have him at 200%.
Do the Loki one.
I can't push everybody higher and then everyone else lower, but is my sound guy still alive?
If my sound guy's alive, I can put everybody lower.
I mean, he owns some of the times.
Dude, triple support is so fucking annoying.
I feel like maybe we should just...
Maybe we should just run triple support at that point.
I mean, maybe we should for sustainability.
Uh...
Did Loki not blame people for once?
I was... Okay, but to be fair, I was getting a lot of peel, too.
I don't really care about banning Thor.
I don't...
It's not really like ban-worthy.
I don't think it's... Are my sound people still alive?
Dude, healers are getting or having a hard time.
Yeah, I mean, I could just... Should I just play back?
Because I kind of... If I'm playing Starlord, I'd melt Thor.
I could play a little bit back, too.
I mean, because I have mobility.
I can use E to get back there.
So, like...
I could just play a little bit more back.
I've been trying to get there.
But what can you do to Thor?
From my POV, Thor is killing me and my supports on cooldown and I can't kill him fast enough to help anybody.
So, either someone needs to come back and help.
Yeah.
I can pull Thor and pull him back.
I don't know if it's worth it, but I can do that.
Starlord's probably better because he actually melts.
I think someone with damage does it.
Sure, it's fine.
Or you just... I mean, I legit...
Skrull girl was good.
You fucking...
You hate me for swapping.
Why are we banning?
I'm still banning Strange.
Groot?
Do we want to get Groot?
Yeah, ban Strange.
We might protect Groot, though.
Oh.
It's better to get Strange up, though.
Yeah, that's true.
Save Luna, right?
Maybe save Invis?
Invis for push, yeah.
We could.
Doki, you play other characters, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll save.
Yeah, I play any support.
Because they banned Sue last game.
Yeah, because like...
I wanted to save Luna just because of the fact that Luna also has her freeze.
But if we have Sue's push, then that works, too.
Who are we banning?
Ours?
Groot, right?
Why?
What did I do?
Yeah, I'll ban Groot.
They're just going to abuse the combo.
Because they were trying to abuse it over and over again.
Oh.
The fuck?
If the Thor is diving, I don't have to play Sarl.
I can play like Namor.
Yeah, yeah.
I think if you play...
Okay.
Sounds so sad.
If I'm in a trouble support, we can do Namor.
But if I'm DPS, go Skrull Girl.
We were legit owning the Thor last game.
When you went Skrull Girl, then you swapped.
That's why I said fuck you.
Wait, wait.
What did you say?
When...
When you were on Skrull Girl, focusing Thor last game, we were like owning him.
And then you swapped to Starlord.
Because you just fucking hate me for some reason.
That's why I said fuck you.
Honestly, I feel like I was doing more against the Thor.
Like at Starlord.
I was shredding him.
I think I'm worried about the damage.
It's so good.
I'm just giving out armor.
You can Namor here though.
Namor is pretty good here.
I would rather Namor Starlord on this point.
Do Namor because you have triple support.
Wait, you have triple?
Oh yeah.
No, oh yeah.
No, I'm playing this.
Please.
Oh, you just want to give out armor.
Oh, min maxing?
Okay, get the Jeff.
Six bubbles.
Grab the extra jump.
Okay.
We have triple support.
We're just fine.
People just don't want double jump.
No, fuck that shit.
We're going to play what?
A lot more around our front line this game.
We'll play front to back.
No, no, no.
We have triple support.
I can be reckless now.
They're super dive.
We can survive any dive.
Walk in here.
They're playing cap as well.
We can fight this on top.
Can we walk up?
Yeah, I'm walking up.
We have cap america on us.
That's fine.
I'm walking up.
Any heals?
Yeah, yeah.
Kill hella.
Wait, focus hella.
Hella half.
I got hella.
I froze cap america.
Kill cap.
Thor is half.
Thor is dead.
Everyone go point.
No more is up top.
Focus cap.
Cap america is on point.
We need to get point control.
Focus cap if we can.
Yeah.
I am ready to put on a show.
They have support now.
I can probably get my ult.
We're leaving.
We're leaving for a sec.
We're good.
I have ult.
I'm gonna ult first.
Come point.
I'm ulting over point.
Thor half.
Thor low.
I'm going to use my next one.
I'm damage boosting.
Oh my god.
I'm damage boosting the cap.
Kill Thor.
I got him.
Cap.
We need to never lose point cap.
Now that we have it.
I can't believe it.
I'm on left side.
I'm gonna play high with you.
I'm staying on point the whole time.
I need heals.
My husband gave him a mistake.
On the side.
We can fight them on top.
I have shield.
I need help.
I froze cap.
Guys, we can't give up point if possible.
I'm on it.
We're down both supports.
We just didn't have...
There's a support ult for that.
I have to go cave it up.
We have double support now.
We're there.
I'm coming soon.
Walk to height first.
I'm walking now.
We have to fight this.
I'm looking to drop in.
I froze him.
Just make them waste ult.
I have to jump in there.
It's so annoying.
More damage will be good.
I need to play DPS.
I can't triple with that.
I don't know what to play.
You can play it.
Ape can play something else.
I think...
I don't play wolves a problem.
I think our frontline can be more aggressive on their backline.
I think you two together, as long as you're getting healed enough from our backline...
I don't think it's an issue.
I think you guys are turning around too much.
Look at their Hella and their squishy smorcs.
Don't worry about the cap.
The cap is bait.
I swear I heard nothing from him.
I was.
I'm here now.
You can 3-4 pump.
Yeah, but the problem is...
I missed my shots on the fucking...
Either way, it's just pressure.
Yeah, I can pressure backline.
I'll just do that.
I think our frontline can pressure backline a bit more.
After I die and use my ult, I think I'm going to swap off to Starlord.
Dude, top right.
Is that a Panther?
I'm going for a dive.
No, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Thor has.
Thor 1.
Thor is still low.
I got him.
Captain America 1.
Just focus on him.
I'm going to ult first.
They didn't use anything.
They used their ult.
You can ult first.
He's looking to dive.
They're looking to dive us now.
Thor can dive.
Let's go.
Walk up.
I have to use it then.
He was going to kill me if I didn't.
Dude, kill the hell...
3, 2, 1.
We have to solve.
I'm dead here.
Kill the support.
Look at Captain America.
Captain America is so low.
They still don't have point.
He still doesn't have point.
I can't walk in.
That's fine.
We're even.
I'm walking in.
I need help.
I got you.
I'm looking at Luna.
Okay, but now I need help.
Thor behind.
Thor on me.
That's where I lose him.
I'm swapping.
I'm going to stay.
Okay.
Can we walk to the left?
This is right side.
I'm at 86.
Can we go backline?
I'm looking at backline.
Backline.
I'm shielding.
Thor is looking.
Thor is looking now.
I have to ult this.
I'm ulting this.
I didn't want to die here.
He died.
He fell off.
Oh my god.
25 more.
Yup.
Actually, I don't think I need it.
I wish I just died for it.
I'll chase backline.
I have to reload.
Hold two.
I'm ulting.
Get in.
I have a Thor in the back.
That's just hitting me.
Nice.
I'm dead.
I couldn't heal.
I froze him.
I pushed him.
I'm too low.
I'm on Luna.
I froze somebody, but I don't know who, but I'm going to die here.
I couldn't ult there.
It's looking good.
Just stay on point.
Just stay on point here.
I'm dead.
I have ult here.
Oh no, I don't.
This guy.
He's trying to stall.
I was trying to kite you the whole time.
I'm just...
I'm saving all my freezes on the dives.
I can only...
I can only freeze two of them.
One of them.
Thor one.
I'm using this.
No, no, no.
We're fine.
I know.
Just kill Cap.
I'm damage boosting.
Just kill him.
They're all damage boosters.
We capped this.
Thor.
Focus Thor.
Nice.
Good stuff.
One more.
Alright.
We almost have two ults.
You're just leaving you guys in the back.
Like, good luck.
They have their support ults.
They didn't use any.
They should have Luna.
I don't think they used the Luna ult yet.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
I honestly don't even know if I want to use this ult.
You can use it to get rid of their support ult.
Maybe.
Yeah, I think just force it out.
Force it out and then Abe can maybe have a...
Or Abe might have it.
Abe, when they support ult, by the way, I'll fuck in front of them, drool, and walk out of it.
Look for that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have been.
Like, outside of the school.
Do I ult?
Can I get it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If we need it, if we need it.
We'll see what the situation is like.
We can just invis the ult on the point then.
We might have to save or a shield for our invisible woman if we use a mag ult.
I can jump it.
It's almost never a problem.
I'm falling now.
I have it.
I don't have it yet.
I'm going back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here with you.
I'm with you.
No more ults.
Throw one up.
Everyone up.
Holding top.
They used cloak.
They're gonna have Luna.
That's it.
They have mag ult.
I don't see a Thor, so careful.
Thor's on the left side.
In, in, in, in.
Oh my god.
Thor's right there.
I can't get to you.
I'm on point.
They accidentally dropped down there.
That's okay.
They have Thor.
They shouldn't have cloak ult yet.
So we should have a free We should have a free ult then.
He's waiting.
I'm trying to get to you.
We're down two.
Yeah, we're down three now.
Oh, they're in.
I need help here.
Oh, sorry man.
Just reset.
It's fine.
He's going to have mag ult again.
Can I just go to point?
Yeah, I gave him snowflake.
They know.
I'm reloading.
Go, go, go, go.
I see it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm taking my Gido here.
Mag one, mag one, mag one.
We can kill him.
They're chasing me so fucking hard.
I missed it.
I missed my freeze.
That was my bad.
We can invisible ult as soon as you get there.
Can you touch it?
Nice.
Help me!
I'm coming in, I'm coming in.
I got her, I got her.
Thor's going to be on me, Thor's going to be on me.
I'm not there yet.
That was
close.
We got one round.
Yeah, that was a close game, close game.
GG.
Oh man, that was rough.
I missed the last few freezes that were important.
But his movement is so...
Because I don't play against a lot of Thors.
I don't play against a lot of Thors.
So predicting Thor's movement is hard because he glides and stuff.
That last round, I needed to predict.
I needed to predict.
I needed to hit those last two freezes.
By the way,
every time I stop the Thor, we win.
Every time we win a fight.
And I had like two people diving me so it was so difficult.
It was so fucking difficult.
Because I had two dive tanks on me every time and I could only freeze one of the dive tanks every time.
And what's really rough is that John or Mayoshi is the same tier as me.
Masayoshi.
So I feel bad because they get a Celestial tank and then they get me.
So I'm the same tier as the other tank player.
So they get like two tanks.
Or anybody.
Maybe like 25 and 0.
I might have the worst record.
I won one.
No, I have one too.
It's alright.
I think somebody hasn't won yet.
Oh wait, no.
Everybody's won one.
Everybody's won at least one.
Cutie is 7-0.
Yeah.
Me and Selene are fighting for second to see if we can make it.
Well you gotta beat xQc then to get it.
I know.
Well we gotta win 2-0 I think because we might win this one.
We'll see.
Wait for what?
Yeah.
Apparently in Marvel Rivals support is the hardest to make an impact.
Because you know all we can do is just keep people alive.
Or freeze them.
And then we have to make sure something has to happen after that.
LOL
So like...
So like that's the roughest part.
That's the roughest part.
Because I can only do as much as um...
I can only have so much of an impact.
But like it was a good game.
It was a really really close game.
I think this was the closest game I've had during the first two.
So definitely the closest game I've had.
And uh...
I had some really insane freezes and stuff.
There.
And I got some kills in there too.
It's just unlucky cause...
Masayoshi or John Store is really good.
And the fact that they have two Celestia...
They have two really good tank players.
And we had one tank player who doesn't really play tank that often too.
So it was...
Yeah, I'm learning a lot.
I have to get to play roles that...
Not roles, I'm on support jail.
LOL Like obviously I shouldn't be playing anything but support.
No, then my next match is with Sleepy again.
Obviously I have to play support.
Because I think if I wasn't on Luna...
If I wasn't on Luna for my team, it would have been even more rough for my team.
It would have definitely been more rough for my team at that point.
If I wasn't freezing the tanks non-stop.
I fixed the sound.
Is the sound better or is it worse?
How's the sound?
I adjusted the discord again.
I'm gonna go get more water.
I'll be back.
He's gonna be on my team again.
Boosted up a little higher.
I'll be right back guys.
Where the fuck did you post it?
In this VC's chat.
In the VC chat?
You click on the little chat icon on our VC?
There we go.
I see it.
Oh!
Right?
You hear that?
That's mushroom music.
My mouth feels so weird because it really sucked.
Because during the plane ride, there was no soft tissues on the plane.
So tissues were like super rough.
So when I was blowing my nose my lips are like the skin is like, you know what I mean?
Like your skin is like super rough and stuff because I feel like what's the word?
Like the scratches and stuff.
So like not the lip like the, yeah.
I don't know how to describe it.
So like last night it was like that.
It's not my lips but it's like the upper area.
The upper area.
The rubbed raw.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's not, like my lips itself aren't chapped, but like it's the bottom and the top part.
Like the sandpaper, yeah.
But I had to blow my nose because I was like I had a cold yesterday.
So yesterday was really bad because it was like super sore because of it.
But like today it's a lot better.
Like it's the bottom and the top part.
And it, oh my gosh, it's been a rough month.
It's been a rough month.
Nothing's really been going very well for me.
Good luck.
Good luck, everybody.
I hope you win.
I hope you all lose.
Except Doki because you're on my team.
Yeah, I was going to say I'm on your team.
Fuck you, Sleepy.
Fuck me, fuck you.
Fuck you.
Do we have DPS players on our team?
I'm pretty sure we have five support players.
Yeah, me too.
I was like telling my chat.
I was like, I'm pretty sure this is a five support team.
I'm with you again.
Oh, wait, wait, no, no, no, we have a...
No, Sina is a squirrel one trick player.
That's why I said five supports.
Oh, you guys are positive.
Oh, okay.
Hey, guys, what's up?
Good vibes then and here's good vibes.
Yeah.
What's up, my boy?
Yeah, what's up, boy?
What's up, boy?
I think I'm the only my boy on the team.
You're the only guy.
Does that count?
Five and a half, I guess.
We'll all my boy in retaliation, okay?
Okay, there we go for the vibes.
Yeah, we will for the vibes.
My boy!
Okay, so...
We're fucked.
Comp wise...
I mean, we just have to run triple support.
But we have zero tank players.
We have zero tank players.
We have literally zero tank players.
But that doesn't help if we don't have a tank player.
So I think we have a tank.
Guys, we have to walk in here.
Because apparently I'm tied for my place.
For second.
I'm also tied against the people that we're playing.
So we have to beat them.
Well, we hope we have someone that's willing to play tank.
Because I'd rather just...
Log off.
Okay, okay.
So I think like maybe the strat would be...
I think that you guys are probably better on heals than I am on heals.
So then I should play tank.
And it might be mid.
But at least the better players...
Sleepy should 100% play DPS.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, okay.
I can play door.
Do you need me to play rocket?
We run rocket.
We have to have a punish.
I think you play scroll girl.
I still need you.
We just need someone to tank.
I also want to note.
We're going against Sykkuno.
Who is the most annoying player in this entire tournament.
By far.
I hate playing against him.
It's so frustrating.
He doesn't have the most fucking obscure pocket.
Magneto.
Or strange or something.
Like no one's ever seen it.
It's never seen the light of day.
But it's a fucking beast in the night.
It's not a beast in the night.
But I think I'm decent at Magneto.
I'm decent at...
Penny.
I can play Groot.
I wouldn't call it decent.
And I can play Thor.
Yeah.
Who fucking toast?
It's okay.
I had three teams.
That was just all support players.
It's okay.
This has been my day.
I can...
I can play Magneto.
I don't know whether I'm the goat.
I don't think I'm the goat.
Oh no, they have a tank player.
Nevermind.
We have five support players and a squirrel.
And a squirrel.
That's basically like...
What if...
Yeah, five support.
And a squirrel.
Fuck it.
Guys, you keep me alive.
I'm a parry.
I can...
I can Magneto.
I think I can Magneto.
Which one of you has more hours?
You were said.
Alright, let's check.
Okay, how about Sleepy checked that.
Whichever one of you is a bit more comfortable on tank should play it.
I'll DPS.
And we have three supports.
I can also DPS too if needed.
My most played tank is Penny.
But I don't think she's a good solo tank.
Unless...
On certain maps.
It's 100% either Mag or Strange.
I have 58 minutes on Strange.
We're so locked in, guys.
I believe in this.
I don't have any hours on this account for Magneto.
But I have played.
I can play him.
I think so.
I can also Magneto.
I could Magneto.
I have played a good bit of Magneto.
What if it's like me and huge mid tanks but the rest of you guys are so good at DPS and support it doesn't matter that we're mid tanks.
That's true.
I think that's very possible.
I'm down to mid tank it up.
If you know how to survive on Magneto that's good enough.
I don't need you pumping I will be self-shielding.
No, I'm kidding.
If you can just know how to LOS things and use your shield and stuff like that and survive on point it's good enough.
I don't need faker gameplay Magneto everything.
I don't think that matters.
Does that sound more like you or me, Sydney?
I played Magneto today and my chat might have been glazing me but they said it was really good.
My chat might be a bunch of glazers.
Guys, tell me the truth.
Everyone's looking at you right now.
Chat, was it good or was it not good?
I'm throwing it into the fray.
Honestly, Sydney I trust you with my life with anything so I feel like you probably do have a really solid You know, let's just like if the first round, you know there's something wrong, we can just keep swapping it up.
Just keep swapping it until it works.
I can play like strange surely.
They said, well, they said it was mid.
But I killed the cloak so that's a double.
Oh, okay.
I've never done that in my life.
Yeah, I didn't do that.
Okay, so we have five support players and they have five DPS players.
Okay, I think first game let's try Syd on Mag and then the rest can fill in the blanks.
I can play DPS too.
Yeah, if you want to play Scorch, you can play Scorch.
Or you can play tank, you know.
You can play support if you want, either one.
I don't want you to play tank, girl.
No offense.
Full offense.
Can I get an invite, Celine?
Oh yeah, for sure.
Sorry.
I can be like, I can be tank, guys.
Thank you.
I can be your hero, babe.
I can be all those things.
I literally was just listening to that song.
I'm glad you could do that.
I want you to know that's what I listen to whenever I solo queue and then I lose and I turn it off.
Yeah.
Did you like that movie, Starstruck?
What movie is that?
Is that what it's from?
I thought that's where it's from.
Oh, I'm not a movie person.
I just know that song.
It's not like Highbrow.
It's like a Disney Channel movie.
I'll just kill myself.
It's fine.
I can tell what these matches are going to be like, guys.
It's alright.
I pretty peaked on that one round I won off of xQc and Shroud.
That was my highlight for the month.
For instance, that was the good thing that happened to me this month.
That was what made everything worth it for this tournament.
That's what made it worth it.
Spider-Man and Bucky because Necros on Spider-Man and Bucky is a terror.
We should ban Spider-Man first.
Just ban Spider-Man first because he's just going to block us over.
I think we ban Wolf first.
I don't think I want to put our solo tank through Wolf.
If they save Spider-Man, we ban Venom.
It's not that big of a deal.
I can play Namor with Luna to counter Spider-Man.
He played Spider-Man against me earlier when I banned Venom and he just instant swapped when I was on Namor.
He hates Namor.
Every Dive character hates Namor.
Yeah, he hates Namor.
They're probably going to ban Namor and Loki which kind of sucks.
You need to target ban Necros.
Who does he play?
I don't think Spider-Man is that bad if he doesn't have Venom with him.
So I think we can just do Venom second.
Wait, Necros is the number one Spider-Man?
Yeah.
To be fair, Spider-Man is considered F tier if you look at the rate.
To be fair.
But he makes it work.
I've seen SK's roll out on Spider-Man and that's scary.
I love your voice, Doki.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, you have such a cute voice.
Thank you.
I'm also sick though so I don't know if it sounds different.
You sound amazing.
Are you ready?
I'm ready!
Okay guys, don't be afraid to tell me that my Magneto sucks and I need to switch.
My Magneto fucking sucks and you need to switch.
Okay, right now we go to our tank player.
What are you going to do, sleepy?
Huh, sleepy?
Do you think Gargura would be proud of you for talking like that?
I don't think she even knows he exists.
My boy?
You know what?
The vibes are high.
Even if we lose, we're going to have fun.
I just got informed to keep my man vibes fucking out of here.
I'll make up the testosterone here.
Are you ready?
I think he's asses.
I don't know if the enemy team is ready though.
DPS up.
She's up.
And support.
Yeah, they got tank players.
They got support players.
Woah!
How many games have you won?
Sleepy, you've won a good amount.
You've won a good amount, bro.
Hey guys, I have one point.
My tier, my ranked tier, they're all tank and DPS players.
And I'm like the only support in my tier.
Literally, they put Shroud, John...
We have our first ban, Wolverine.
We have our first ban.
Yeah, we're banning Wolf.
Yeah, I think it's just like...
It's just a nightmare.
In general.
What?
Goodbye, Wolf.
I thought you liked that, Sleepy.
Nope.
Sure?
I'm pretty sure your chat would agree with me.
I could enjoy it, but like...
Not so much.
What do you want to protect if they ban Namor first?
Sleepy, pay attention!
What are we protecting if they ban Namor?
No, then save Spiderman.
I don't know what to save.
That's so weird.
I don't know what to protect.
I mean, I could protect Loki, but like...
I'm not really gonna play it.
Yeah, don't protect Loki.
There's no point.
At best, we have Sue.
If we are getting died too hard, I can just play Sue.
Should we just protect Magneto?
Someone click something!
Luna!
Oh, yay!
Alright, we're banning Venom, right?
Yeah, Venom.
Guys, sorry.
Every single time I've played today, we've missed a ban or a protect.
Like every single time.
I noticed that.
You know what I noticed?
The first time it happened, I was like, was that on purpose?
Guys, you know what I noticed?
Toast has the most points in his tier.
I think he's rigging.
I think he's rigging his matches.
I'm pretty.
He wants to win all the skins for himself.
Wait, so we're going...
What are we going again?
I think we're going triple support and then Sleepy wanted DPS.
You wanted DPS?
Alright, sounds good.
Loki, do you have a support you prefer?
I can play any support.
Do you want me on Cloak and Dagger?
I do think if you have the fucking dirtiest Daniel Loki, Loki's good.
I'm going to ban it.
You are not paying attention!
They banned it.
Should I D&D?
You should Cloak it.
Cloak and Dagger is so good.
At best if we get died by Spider-Man, keep your push for Spider-Man.
What are our thoughts about 2-2-2?
2-2-2...
I can try...
Oh, I can do...
Penny.
I can also do Penny.
Alright, let's try this first.
Okay, shall we go left?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm the tank.
I believe.
I'll put...
Oh my god, there's a Spider-Man!
Why are you guys all here?
Wait, what?
You guys split up.
The Spider-Man is just going to...
The Spider-Man is just going to camp.
We should make sure...
Yep, there he is.
Push?
Yeah, push.
We can go through the stairs.
Yeah, let's go through the stairs.
Come through the left.
I'm upstairs now.
Spider-Man is low.
He's looking for a health pack.
Karrison, Spider-Man is behind you.
Thank you.
I'm trying.
I'm shooting you.
Oh my god.
I'm frozen.
Oh, wait.
Thanks.
I have no idea why I targeted that, but...
I'm pushing here.
Yep, yep, yep.
We're up one.
Tank can drop.
Tank can fall.
I'm looking at the supports.
I'm looking at Pacuno.
Dead.
I'm frozen.
Any heals?
I'm dead.
Oh, I'm going to die to...
Oh my god.
We can win this.
You're even.
Max one.
You have no supports though.
I'm going to die though.
It's all you.
Okay.
Support, let's all stay...
We all have to stay together.
We can't split up.
Because...
Yeah, because when the Spider-Man died me...
We all...
The other supports were...
The other supports were in front of me.
So I need everybody to group up here.
Same thing.
We just go through top.
Okay, we all group up together.
We all wait for a tank.
I'm running.
I'm coming.
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
Fuck you, Spider-Man.
They're going to have Spider-Man ult.
I'm just going to hear the Spider-Man, please.
I pushed him away.
Nice.
We can kill him.
Go up.
Drop point.
Help Sleepy.
I didn't realize he...
Support all you needed.
I'm ulting.
Protect our supports.
I'm ulting for you.
We have my ult.
They ulted as well.
I know.
I'm using it now.
I have to run back.
I'm damaged boosting.
I got you.
I'm shielding you.
I have you, Sleepy.
I'm damaged boosting.
3, 2, 1.
I got him.
Kill him fast.
Yeah, you can.
Huge ult.
The Punisher can destroy the ult.
It pops fast.
It's fine.
Push up.
I can kill.
I got you.
We have each other.
I'm shielding you.
I'm pushing him away.
Nice bubble.
I don't have anything.
That was our last fight.
We might...
If someone can swap to Strange right now and the TP.
It's a little slow.
I don't think we're going to be able to do this.
Oh god.
You got this.
Jump in.
You did it.
What?
Where did the point go?
I swapped.
Okay.
You jumped right in.
I'm shielding you again.
I'm trying.
It's okay.
I tried.
MT everybody.
We got 60%.
I hate this.
Guys.
I'm that Spider-Man.
I hate it.
We can just ban.
I'm willing to go...
Second tank.
I think Penny would be sick here.
Honestly with their team comp.
Alright.
Let's do it to them, guys.
Now I know.
When I swap off of Strange, the portal disappears.
No.
You could have stayed on tank.
It was fine.
Yeah.
It was last-ditch effort.
It was more so you don't swap off.
I've never done that before.
You got that portal.
That's a high level play you did there.
You've learned something.
People do that in competitive.
Guys, I've been doing cardio simulator this entire round.
I don't even know what...
They don't...
They don't Strange, right?
Can I play DPS next round?
I just want one round of DPS.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't think Wolverine is...
I think you guys might be getting the better of the treatment here.
If he goes BP, it's gonna be a rough day.
Yeah.
So we ban Spider-Man and he goes BP.
He will always get Namor first, huh?
But I can...
There's Nerf Graves coming in.
I see him.
Yeah, he's low.
He needs this.
He had to rush Twitch Rivals, guys.
His Twitch Rivals was really rough.
Haha!
Oh, is he already here?
It's called the Spider-Man rollout.
I'm trying, Doki.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Oh, god.
Fuck you, Cuck.
I need you in the back.
I'm with you.
Okay, punish your turret.
Just cover the Spider-Man in the back.
Yep, he's here.
I broke the turret.
I got you.
But you have to get me, too.
Oh, fuck.
I'm dead.
I have you.
Oh, god.
I just froze Spider-Man.
You can kill him.
Oh, there he came back.
Oh, god.
It's fine.
It's so good.
Oh, fuck Spider-Man.
Spider-Man.
Hey, NG, guys.
Oh, my god.
Oh, fuck Spider-Man.
Yay, I get to play DPS.
You play DPS.
You deserve it.
I deserve it.
You're right.
If I kill him on DPS, I'm gonna make a clickbait video and be like, Necros dies to a support player on DPS.
Is that our last one?
No, we didn't win.
Our next one is our last one.
I've been playing Rivals for so long, my brain is foggy.
It feels like pudding up there.
Oh, so what is our lineup gonna be?
I guess you and Cinna on DPS and then we...
You guys want a 2-2-2?
I'm down for 2-2-2.
1-3-2?
Or 1-2-3?
Actually, I'm also down for 2-1-3.
Or a 2-1-3?
Yeah.
Wait, but we can't 2-1-3 if Doki is DPSing.
This is my last hurrah.
My last hurrah.
I was on support Jill for so long.
I can 1...
We can 1-2-3.
Yeah, we can 1-2-3.
Are we selecting the map or are they selecting the map?
They're selecting it.
Okay, I'll just be like, ready.
I can try solo tanking.
I'm down.
I'm down for whatever.
I will just say it when I'm going up and then leave it to your guys' hands.
Wait, we pick the map?
Sleepy, what map?
I just do Koth, get it over with.
Any Koth map.
Just let him pick.
Choose your best rollout.
No preference.
So then we just ban Spidey off rip.
Yeah, he'll be like, I'm going to choose my best Spiderman rollout map and then we ban Spiderman.
Wait, he chose this map?
His team got knocked out on that map.
I know.
Who did he lose to?
How has he lost?
Oh, you did?
Must be nice.
But then he just starts target banning me every fucking time and I can't beat him anymore.
Every fucking time ever since then.
That's smart though.
You guys want to play Psylocke?
Am I hitting Mag?
I think Eugene was down to solo Mag.
Yeah.
Does that put me on DPS or heals?
I can also play tank.
I'm going to feed so fucking hard.
I'm sorry guys.
I haven't played Psylocke in so long.
Sleepy, ban.
Where's Spiderman?
Oh my god.
I was going to be like, after all that...
Where's Spiderman?
I'm going to ban Namor.
Do we ban BP then?
I'm down to ban BP.
He wants to have fun.
I'm going to ban Namor.
Wait, who am I saving?
Why don't we just save Loki then?
Let's save Loki and ban BP.
At least you guys can have some fun.
Alright, ban BP, right?
Yeah, no dive heroes for you.
Unless he plays Ironfist.
He plays Ironfist too, by the way.
Yeah, I was about to say, he thirds Ironfist.
Yeah, his sister.
You know what?
Actually, no.
I feel like BP is easier to shut down versus Ironfist.
Yeah, Ironfist has damage mitigation.
Oh, yeah.
No doubt.
You can't push him away.
Yeah, can't push him away.
Honestly, Sleepy, I think you should play Loki and just...
Yeah.
I think this is good.
Do you want Luna or Mantis?
Your preference.
Are you better at freezing?
Are you better at freezing or sleeping?
That's the thing.
Sleeping.
Because you gotta sleep the Wolverine every time.
So like...
Not every time, but it's your job now.
I knew I was done after the first game.
Necro's probably...
He doesn't even need this.
Because his team needs it.
His team don't need it either.
I feel like.
Necro, you're literally partnered with rivals.
You can get any skin you want.
Wait, he's partnered?
He personally knows the devs.
He really doesn't need this.
He personally knows the devs too.
So it's like, you don't even need the skins.
At least our vibes are good.
I've never been sponsored by Marvel Rivals.
I need this.
He's on Iron Fist.
Supports stick together.
Hold hands, everyone.
Okay, you're walled off.
He's lurking.
I know he is.
He's asleep.
Oh my god, they're so low though.
Oh my god,
they're so low.
The crew was so low.
I can ult after this.
We're doing this.
I have ult here, but I think they have...
Yeah, they used one of them.
I can ult them.
Yeah, I'm pushing up now.
I'm flanking them.
I'm gonna ult them as soon as I see a support player.
Yeah, I got the Luna ult out.
I couldn't live there.
I have ulti soon.
They don't have support ults.
Yeah, I'm ulting.
Oh my god, the Mantis ult actually saved me.
I'm still alive.
I'm blocking this Luna.
She's shifting.
Oh my god, we got the point.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I'm gonna walk up a little bit.
I got him half.
He's half.
I'm here.
I'm back on point.
I don't want to get iron fisted.
Wait, their grid is so low.
I can match.
I blinded them.
I'll ult after this.
Everyone point.
Stay in my ult.
Necro's.
You guys are okay.
I got the Luna ult out.
Okay, I'm easy.
I can go.
Just stay on point.
Fight on point.
I'm on grid.
Grid's one.
Oh, they're so low.
I'm coming back.
Oh my god.
Play on point.
I got Wolverine.
I got Luna.
I couldn't get out of shift.
Just fight on point.
Don't leave point.
We're ulting.
I have ult soon.
Just keep fighting on point.
We don't give up cap.
I'm on it.
I got the Luna ult out.
Just stay on point.
I need help.
I'm running back.
Oh shit.
We have one fight.
I can touch if needed.
Hey, you know what guys?
I'm proud of us right now.
I can touch.
Thank you.
I'm on it now.
I had to.
They were looking for me.
I'm trying.
I made it.
I'm dead.
I'm not dead.
Fight on point.
Don't leave point.
Nice.
Wolverine is out.
I got the wrong guy.
I can't enter.
Nice.
I tried to stay on point.
That wasn't the worst one.
No, that was so much better.
I think we get next map.
No, I believe in us.
I mean, we did pretty well, I think.
I don't know what's going on with comms.
I don't know what's going on with comms right now.
I don't know.
Honestly, we are.
Maybe I'll go hella for you.
I'm going to go hella for you, Snoopy.
They banned Namor.
Yeah.
I saw Luna opening.
Do you see people banning Luna instead of Namor?
I was like, fuck it, we can run it.
We should have had three bans so we could get Iron Fist out.
I'm saying, fuck this guy.
Somebody in my chat just said Nekros isn't even trying.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's just fucking around.
Yeah, this guy is fucking sweating out of his mind, I can tell.
I've managed this all.
Yeah, let's get point control.
He's already above us, Jesus Christ.
This fucking roach.
He has his rollout on.
I hear him stepping on the metal.
He's on me.
Yup, yup, yup.
Nice, I got him.
You should respawn now.
I'm back.
Welcome.
Kill the cuck, kill the cuck, kill the cuck, kill the cuck.
Oh, he just got shielded.
That's fine.
Just fight on point again.
I have shift.
I got him, I got him.
Road's low, road's low.
Nice.
Did you just backstab him?
Yeah, I scratched his back a couple times.
I have ult here.
Let them have the point then.
Just play on this thing right here.
For LOS.
Let them out, we can have ult.
I don't know what spells they have.
I have ulti, I have ulti for this fight.
Oh, he dropped back down, I think he's going around.
Be careful.
I'm 90%, I just need to hit once.
Oh, he got shielded.
He's parried already.
I have shift on the side, so I'm okay.
Road's low, grid's low.
I have ult.
I have blue on the ammo.
I got my ulti.
Oh my god, that's a lot of ults.
Just die on point, I guess.
Oh, and they grew an ulti for me.
That's five ults, right?
They only have hook and dagger ults.
That's a lot of ults.
They have hook ult.
No.
I can't believe it.
For little old me, they solo grew an ulti on me.
That's just rude.
I'm going up.
Grid's low.
Wolverine's on the right, can I walk in?
Yep.
Oh, they pushed.
Just back up.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Oh shit, they're hard pushing me there.
That was my bad.
I should've just stayed with you guys.
I'm going to grab ult and go.
Come forward, come forward to point.
Okay, walking, walking, walking.
I'm walking, I'll walk, I'll walk.
This guy's just punching me in the back.
Fuck.
Yeah, yeah, looking at him.
He's asleep.
He's solo.
I'm walled off here.
I'm just getting walled non-stop.
Oh my god, I'm going to get bombed.
Oh, I have you.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay, okay, walking, walking.
I got Cloak, I got Cloak.
Or I'm going to die, fuck.
Groot's one, Groot's one.
The cuck, the cuck, the cuck.
Oh my god, he's getting buggered here.
I can't even heal you through that.
He got in the eyes, dude.
I'm so dead.
I'm coming over.
He's behind us.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh, sorry, I didn't do it.
Oh, yeah, it's okay.
There's so many walls.
Like, what do I do against that?
NT, NT.
It's a tough one.
That, like, they literally have someone for everything.
Yeah.
For an all-support team, we really held their, you know.
First time, guys.
That was my third team with all-support.
Is anyone in the final running?
I don't know.
It depends whether or not Kony wins his games for me.
Oh, I'm also waiting on Kony to see if they win I'm out.
Wait, but then, like, you guys are tiebreaker then, right?
Wait, no, Cindy, you're not in...
You're with...
Your bracket is Iman, Toast, Ray, Tarik, and Abe.
Yeah.
But, so, basically, Toast isn't playing because he's the tournament organizer.
Oh.
So, right now, it's me and Tarik.
But if Poki wins the next two, then I'm out.
But if she... Yeah.
I go to tiebreaker if she only wins one, but if she wins the next two, then I'm out.
So, I'm kind of just, like, waiting also to see how Kony and Poki's game goes.
Oh.
Yeah.
Well, thanks for the game.
GG's, guys.
They were fun.
It was fun.
Bye-bye, GG's.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Alright.
Yeah.
Um...
You know, um...
We won the game that matters.
Wait, what?
To be fair, I was either gonna...
I'm just glad... Okay, originally, I was actually gonna get the...
They were actually trying to put me in the leader spot, and then I got moved down a tier.
Um...
I got moved down a tier.
I was like, oh, thank God I got moved down a tier, because I was like, this Poki sucks, because I was like, oh, man, I feel bad.
But then I realized, when I got moved down a tier, it was still similar.
It was still a very similar situation, um, with me being the only support player on my tier as well, so I was just like, man...
That's so unlucky, because I was like the only support player in my tier, while everyone else gets to be the tank and DPS, and I was just like, oh...
That's rough for me.
That's so rough.
And then, and then Toast posted the matchups, the teams, and I was like, wait, aren't these mostly support players on my team?
So I went in the tournament knowing what was gonna happen.
I was like, I was like, I was like, just have fun, just have fun, Doki.
It's just here to get to know the people, um, get to know the people, and like, uh, just have, like, talk to the people you've never been able to talk to before.
Uh...
But...
I got, I got abandoned by RNGesus.
I did.
I...
RNG was definitely not on my side.
Oh.
We're at least four support players every every time.
Yeah, but like, the thing is, the lower tier ranks were mostly support players, and it's supposed to be like, um, it's supposed to be the top two tiers were the DPS and tank players, but like, unfortunately, I was not a DPS or tank player, so like, unfortunately,
it was a debuff for whoever got me, because it was just another support player.
But we won.
We did win the one round that matters.
We did win the one round that matters, guys.
That's, that's all that matters.
Um...
But yeah, no, I had a great time talking to people who I've never been able, who I've never had a chance to talk to before.
It's like that my OBS didn't work, um, in the beginning.
Uh, and we had a bad day.
Oh man, no.
I have been having a very unlucky, like, last two to three weeks.
My last, the year of the snake has not been going so well for me.
Uh...
Like, I just hope, I just hope that I get better health-wise soon, because like, that's the only thing I can control at the moment.
No, wait, not control, but that's the only thing that I can like, um...
that I hope to be able to like, not worry too much about.
Hahaha.
Um, but yeah, uh, I was gonna play rank after, but wait, let me see.
Uh...
I'm not sure if my, if, I was gonna ask like Gomez if he wants to duo, but I don't think he's awake, because I don't know if I want to solo after today.
I don't know.
After today, I don't know guys.
I don't know if I want to go through that.
Hahaha.
It's been pretty rough guys, not gonna lie.
It's been pretty rough.
Uh...
Yeah, it's like...
Hahaha.
Okay, but look at my...
Guys, guys, competitive is what matters.
Hahaha.
Com...
Competitive is what matters, guys.
This is, this is what's important.
Guys, this is what's important, okay?
Right, right here.
And this is what's important, everybody.
I just thought, you know what, maybe I can win a quick play game, you know what?
Maybe my luck turns around here and I win a quick play game.
Hahaha.
The life of a support player.
The life of being a support main.
Alright.
Maybe, maybe I won't play support after.
Oh my gosh, okay.
You know what, maybe give me here.
Hahaha.
Alright, it's alright.
Maybe, maybe I'll have a good support game.
Oh, the bubble overlay is still on?
I'll turn it off now.
I'll play a support game and if my, if like Gomez isn't awake by then, then like, then we're just gonna call it here.
I was thinking maybe we'll just get Eternity on stream.
Oh my god.
A normal, no it's not a normal comp.
It's literally a Hulk player.
Hahaha.
Oh my god, that hurt.
That actually, I've never seen so many losses.
That actually hurt to see.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Debuff by being a support player.
I literally was tempted to be like, can I I was like, oh it's for fun.
It doesn't matter what my team is.
Then now I'm like, oh man, that was Hahaha.
You're not Nekros.
I literally just fought Nekros himself.
Get out of my lobby.
What is he doing?
What is our Like, what the fuck are these guys doing?
Hahaha.
It was fun.
Everything's, you're not, he's actually not him.
I literally had to fight a fucking raid boss today.
Honestly, like, um.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, you're such a coward.
You're such a little coward.
Oh, you're such a bitch.
I think we could have countered it.
Countered Nekros more.
Oh, he's just not having a good time.
Not gonna lie.
No healing can save that.
Hahaha.
You're definitely not him.
Oh my god, you're definitely not him.
Holy shit.
Shoot this.
Shoot this, shoot this.
Shoot, guys, you're not gonna shoot it?
That's cool.
Guys, please.
Okay, that's fine.
Hahaha.
Guys, I need a win.
Oh, you're such a coward.
You're actually such a little bitch.
You're so bad.
Hahaha.
These movements are so predictable now.
I gotta fix that win rate.
I just gotta have that one win in that leader in the history.
Just that one win is all that matters.
Playing nice?
People weren't playing nice when I was in the fucking five support team three times.
Hahaha.
Why weren't people playing nice when I had to deal with that?
For three of my teams.
Why did no one show me mercy when that happened?
Hahaha.
Okay, guys, you don't jump when I ult.
Disappear.
Just gonna dance.
Guys, I need you guys.
I'm gonna die here.
Oh, this is where I die.
This is where I die.
Okay, our hook.
Like, okay, guys.
Oh my, guys.
What the fuck?
This is my villain backstory.
It truly is.
I need to get back on point.
Never leave point.
Never leave point, Hulk.
Oh, this is where he dies.
That's for sure.
This is definitely where he dies.
DPS Jeff?
Jeff is left-throw.
It doesn't fucking matter.
Hahaha.
He's not meta in higher elo.
Unless you're like a pure one-trick Jeff player, you have to play Jeff in triple support.
And even then, he's such a throw.
He's not like an actual pick in higher elo.
Triple support is like Cloak, Luna, Mantis, and Invis woman.
Or Loki.
Either works.
Yeah.
His ult, it's because his ult is not a defensive ult.
So like, because his ult isn't offensive, there's no reason to play Jeff because he... Aww.
Hahaha.
Aww.
That's sad.
That sucks.
He's looking for it again.
He's looking for it.
He's doing that fucking TikTok clip.
She's trying to do a TikTok clip.
That fucking Invisible woman.
There she is.
Bro.
Oh, okay.
I mean, thank God.
Hahaha.
Adam?
Last season, yeah.
Sure.
Last season, Adam was viable.
Okay, let's just...
Alright, guys, guys.
Come on, guys.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I'm just... Yippee.
Woo.
Yippee.
I guess I'll just...
Whoa, do you see all of them looking at me?
I'm not gonna live.
I...
Hahaha.
Oh shit, nice.
Please, I worked so hard getting there.
Hahaha.
Oh my God.
We actually managed to claim it back.
We went triple support?
Are you... Okay.
Hahaha.
You can't leave triple support.
Not even in quick play.
That's crazy.
Okay, they're leading just a little bit.
None of us can ever leave triple support, I guess.
Hahaha.
Wait, what?
Where's your ult?
You know what, fuck this.
I'm playing strange.
I'm gonna learn strange right now.
Hahaha.
Fuck this.
If I know anything, I know strange is fucking op as fuck.
Alright, here we go.
If I know anything about this game.
Alright.
Oh, nevermind.
Nevermind.
That felt terrible.
Hahaha.
Now I know why I don't play tank.
I think today's just the fuck...
I think it's just the fucked up month.
I think I got all my wins just from rank.
Legitimately all my... all my fucking...
You're so stupid.
Okay.
Hahaha.
I say it as I get frozen.
Bro, she literally stood still.
I was just like, what are you doing?
I was so confused.
She has ult.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that Captain America?
Oh my god, is that a tank right there?
Holy shit.
Oh, fuck it.
Oh my god.
That was a tank.
We actually have a tank.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Someone please.
Like... oh, he's just standing there.
He doesn't even care.
Wait, what the fuck?
What is she doing here?
What the fuck is this Invisi-woman doing?
Oh no.
Okay.
Nice, she's out.
I hear her.
Like, I hear the Invisi-woman, which is very annoying too.
Like, I'm bumping into her.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, fuck no.
Nice.
Oh my god.
This Invisi-woman is so annoying.
I hate her footsteps.
She's just like, pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa.
Pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa.
I'm like, oh, please shut up.
Stop making noises.
He has Wolverine, I can tell.
He wants to use it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're - I don't want to jinx this right now.
I'm a little afraid.
Oh my god, we did it.
We broke the curse.
We did it.
My leaderboard doesn't look that- How do we have- Okay.
Oh my god.
We did it.
My leaderboard doesn't look that bad.
Oh my god.
Alright, he's out of way.
So I'm going to call it here, everybody.
Alright, guys.
Tomorrow, I'm resting.
The day after tomorrow is going to be our anniversary when I return.
I don't have much planned for tomorrow- for the day after tomorrow.
I'm going to be really frank with you guys.
It's just more so I'm most likely- I don't have anything really special.
I've been tired a lot.
So I couldn't really plan anything for it.
So I really hope you guys still want to celebrate it with me.
I still have fun.
I get to interact with a lot of people today.
I got to do some sick freezes.
I really wanted to try to get Eternity on stream, but I don't want to do it solo.
It's been fucking rough.
After the games we had, it's fucking rough.
I don't want to do it solo.
I don't want to play solo.
I'm glad to be back.
I'm going to be doing regular schedule stuff.
We're back again.
There's going to be no vacation or anything or me disappearing for the next couple of months.
So we're back to regular scheduled regular scheduled DokiBerry content.
I'm super excited.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Guys, I just realized I didn't eat anything at all today.
All I did was just hydrate.
Oh my gosh.
Guys, I'm not a human anymore.
Anyway, bye guys.
Bye.